This episode is brought to you by the Lloyd's 5K House Deposit, and this is something that was last seen in 1996. Yeah, so the 1990s looks now like a lost golden age of prosperity and positivity, doesn't it? Think of the sort of the advent of the Blair administration in 1997, all the enthusiasm and excitement that surrounded that, the economic growth at the time, the technological developments, the sort of sense of an endless golden summer where everybody is listening to Blair and Oasis and looking forward to. to buying their first houses. And that, of course, takes us to mortgages. Now, the good news is that in a nod to the 1990s, Lloyds are offering 5K deposit mortgages to first-time buyers. So search 5K first-time buyer. 1996 average first-time buyer deposits are based on ONS data. Subject to status, your home may be repossessed if you don't keep up repayments and conditions apply.
本集节目由劳埃德银行（Lloyd's）5K房屋首付贷款赞助播出，这项服务上一次出现还是在1996年。没错，现在的20世纪90年代看起来就像是一个失落的繁荣与积极的黄金时代，不是吗？想想1997年布莱尔政府上台时的那种盛况，周围洋溢的热情与兴奋，当时的经济增长，技术的发展，那种仿佛无尽的金色夏天，每个人都在听着布莱尔和绿洲乐队（Oasis）的歌，期待着购买他们的第一套房子。当然，这让我们想到了抵押贷款。好消息是，为了向90年代致敬，劳埃德银行为首次购房者提供了5000英镑首付的抵押贷款。所以，请搜索“5K首次购房者”。1996年首次购房者的平均首付额基于英国国家统计局（ONS）的数据。受个人信用状况限制，如果您未能按时还款，您的房屋可能会被收回，且适用相关条款。
A lawyer's wealth was put on board a guinea ship bound to America as a present to a friend in that country. It was tame and armless as a kitten and therefore not confined but suffered to walk about the ship at pleasure. A stately full-grown English
一位律师的财富被装上一艘开往美国的几内亚船，作为送给该国一位朋友的礼物。它像小猫一样温顺且没有爪子，因此没有被关起来，而是被允许在船上随意走动。一只雄壮的成年英国
Mastiff belonging to the captain disposing the weakness of the young lion frequently took its food by far. and often turned it out of his lodging-box when he had a moin to repose therein himself. The young lion nevertheless grew daily in soys and strength, and the voyage being long, he became at last a more equal match for the Mastiff, who, continuing his insults, received a stunning blow from the lion's paw that fetched his skin over his ears, and deterred him from any further from any
獒犬属于船长，它仗着那只幼狮的弱小，经常抢走它的食物，还经常在自己想在里面休息时，把幼狮从它的窝里赶出来。尽管如此，幼狮每天都在长大，力量也在增强。航程很长，最终它长得足以与獒犬抗衡。獒犬继续它的欺凌行为，结果遭到了狮子的一记重击，打得它皮开肉绽，从此再也不敢
future contest with such growing strength, regretting that he had not rather secured its friendship than provoked its enmity. So that was a chilling parable, and it was first published in the general advertiser on the 2nd of January 1770. Two months before, the event that Americans call the Boston Massacre, and that's the moment when British troops who were being attacked by a hostile mob, fired on the crowd and kill no fewer than five Americans. And this so-called massacre was a crucial episode in the process that would see the 13 rebel colonies of North America secede from the mother country, Britain. They won a war that lasted eight years.
与这种日益增长的力量进行任何未来的较量，后悔自己当初没有与它建立友谊，反而招致了它的敌意。这就是那则令人不寒而栗的寓言，它首次发表于1770年1月2日的《总广告报》（General Advertiser）上。就在两个月前，发生了美国人所称的“波士顿惨案”，当时英国军队遭到敌对暴徒的袭击，向人群开火，造成不少于五名美国人死亡。这场所谓的惨案是北美13个反叛殖民地脱离母国英国这一进程中的关键事件。他们赢得了一场持续八年的战争。
And with the aid of the French, they established themselves as the United States of America, as an independent and sovereign republic. And this summer marks the 250th anniversary of the Declaration of Independence. And Tom, we're marking it by exploring the lives of four of the founding fathers, as they would have called themselves. So in our first episode we talked about George Washington, the most celebrated of the founding fathers, unquestionably the one with the worst teeth,
在法国人的帮助下，他们建立了美利坚合众国，作为一个独立且主权的国家。今年夏天是《独立宣言》发表250周年。汤姆，我们通过探索四位“国父”（他们自己这样称呼）的生活来纪念这一时刻。在第一集中，我们谈到了乔治·华盛顿，他是最著名的国父，毫无疑问也是牙齿最糟糕的一位，
but he did not sign the Declaration of Independence. Now, today, we are with. with the first of the two signatories that we're talking about in this series. And this is the man who wrote that parable about the mastiff and the lion cub. And that is a man called Benjamin Franklin. Correct. And I think the meaning of that parable is very clear. The mastiff, the kind of pedigree dog is Britain.
但他并没有签署《独立宣言》。今天，我们来谈谈本系列中提到的两位签署人中的第一位。他就是写下那则关于獒犬和幼狮寓言的人，他叫本杰明·富兰克林。没错。我认为那则寓言的含义非常明确。那只獒犬，那种纯种狗，代表英国。
And the lion cub is America. And Franklin is basically warning the British. don't push us Americans around, assuming that we are always going to be as puny as we currently are, because we are going to grow up and the time may come when we will end up in a position to push you around, a chilling and, as it has proven, prophetic message for the British. And Franklin was 64 when he wrote that parable, but he would live another two decades after writing it, And he would spend those 20 years doing everything that he could to make that prophecy come true. So he would end up a huge influence on the course of the war.
而那只幼狮代表美国。富兰克林基本上是在警告英国人：不要欺负我们美国人，不要以为我们永远会像现在这样弱小，因为我们会长大，终有一天我们会处于能够欺负你们的位置。这对英国人来说是一个令人不寒而栗且事后证明具有预言性的信息。富兰克林写下那则寓言时已经64岁了，但他在此后又活了二十年，并且他将这二十年全部用来尽其所能让那个预言成真。因此，他最终对战争进程产生了巨大的影响。
It is Franklin, who more than anyone else serves to bring the French in on the side of the Americans with kind of massive consequences. But he's also a huge, huge influence on the character of this infant American Republic. And he is the only man who signs all four of the kind of the foundational documents of the United States. So as we've just heard, he signs the Declaration of Independence. But he also signs the treaty with France that brings the French in on the side of the Americans, the news of which is greeted by George Washington with such excitement enthusiasm that he drops his dignity and Danes to play a game of cricket. He also signs the peace treaty with Britain
正是富兰克林，比任何人都更有效地促使法国站在美国一边，产生了巨大的后果。但他对这个初生的美国共和国的性格也有着极其巨大的影响。他是唯一一位签署了美国所有四份奠基性文件的人。正如我们刚才听到的，他签署了《独立宣言》。但他还签署了与法国的条约，促使法国站在美国一边，乔治·华盛顿得知这一消息后兴奋不已，以至于他放下了尊严，屈尊去打了一场板球。他还签署了与英国的和平条约，
that ends the war and he signs the Constitution. So four kind of massive, massive documents in the history of the United States. So in the future episodes, we'll be talking about Hamilton and whether he deserves its place on the $10 bill.
结束了战争，并签署了《宪法》。所以，这四份文件在美国历史上具有极其重大的意义。在未来的剧集中，我们将讨论汉密尔顿，以及他是否配得上出现在10美元纸币上。
But Franklin is on the $100 bill and do you think he deserves that place? I think he completely does it. I'm going to lay my cards on the table. I think Franklin is an incredibly impressive man, but he's also, I think, a very appealing man. Most revolutionaries I tend not to find very appealing because they're very, they inclined towards the dogmatic, I think.
但富兰克林出现在100美元纸币上，你认为他配得上那个位置吗？我认为他完全配得上。我要摊牌了。我认为富兰克林是一个令人难以置信的杰出人物，但我认为他也是一个非常有魅力的人。大多数革命者我往往觉得不太有魅力，因为我认为他们倾向于教条主义。
But Franklin is a very, very jovial presence. He's a pleasure to have on this series, I think. And he is, he's kind of expressive of, I think, the most kind of appealing aspect of American exceptionalism. So he, you know, everyone can see him. He's balding. He's got his shoulder-length hair, slightly kind of jowly face. He has this kind of expression of mingled amiability and resolve.
但富兰克林是一个非常、非常风趣的人。我认为他在这个系列中出现是一种荣幸。而且他表达了美国例外论中最吸引人的一面。所以，你知道，每个人都能看到他。他秃顶，留着齐肩长发，脸颊略显下垂。他有一种混合了和蔼与决心的表情。
And I think it's no less authentic for being very, very carefully curated. He is the absolute image of this kind of American patriot sage. And people not just in America, but across Europe, as we will see, absolutely love him for it. So he is in the. 18th century, by Miles, the most famous American. And it's a key part of the kind of the diplomatic weight that he brings to the war effort. You say American. Would Franklin have called himself an American? That's the interesting question for much of his life. Yes. And by the end, he would have called himself exclusively American, I think. But you are right to put your finger on this.
我认为这种形象即使经过非常精心的策划，也依然真实。他绝对是这种美国爱国贤者的化身。不仅在美国，而且在整个欧洲，正如我们将要看到的，人们绝对爱戴他。所以，他是18世纪最著名的美国人，遥遥领先。这是他为战争努力所带来的外交分量中的关键部分。你说“美国人”。富兰克林会称自己为美国人吗？这是他一生中大部分时间里一个有趣的问题。是的。到最后，我认为他会称自己为纯粹的美国人。但你指出了这一点是对的。
Of all the founding fathers, he is the one who is also the most British. Hence the voice. I mean, everyone in the American colonies, their accents, I think, are more British than American at this point. But Franklin, he spends a third of his life in Britain. He was living in London when he wrote that parable. That parable was published in a London newspaper. And for the previous six decades, he had reckoned himself a completely proud, a completely loyal Englishman. So in the Seven Years War, the war in which Washington served as a colonial commander and then got very resentful because he didn't get given the promotion that he thought was his due. Franklin had served Washington essentially as his kind of unofficial wagon master.
在所有国父中，他是最像英国人的一位。这就是口音的原因。我的意思是，当时美国殖民地的每个人，他们的口音我认为都比美国口音更像英国口音。但富兰克林，他一生中有三分之一的时间是在英国度过的。他写那则寓言时就住在伦敦。那则寓言发表在伦敦的一份报纸上。在过去的六十年里，他一直认为自己是一个完全自豪、完全忠诚的英国人。所以，在七年战争中，华盛顿作为殖民地指挥官服役，后来因为没有得到他认为应得的晋升而感到非常愤慨。富兰克林基本上是作为华盛顿非官方的后勤主管为他服务的。
But Franklin wasn't in a stront with the British about it. Franklin thought Britain was great and goes to Britain as a result. And that parable, when he wrote it in 1770, he wasn't writing it as someone who thought that America should declare independence. He was writing it as a warning as someone who admired Britain and indeed was hugely loyal to George III, whose coronation he had attended. And Franklin described George the third as the best of kings, the most amiable of kings. So there is a kind of fascinating question there. What is it that turns him? What is it that makes him into a founding father? And I think the story of, let's call it, Franklin's journey
但富兰克林并没有因此与英国人闹翻。富兰克林认为英国很棒，并因此去了英国。当他在1770年写下那则寓言时，他并不是以一个认为美国应该宣布独立的人的身份写的。他是以一个钦佩英国、并且确实对乔治三世（他曾参加过其加冕典礼）非常忠诚的人的身份，写下这则警告。富兰克林称乔治三世为“最好的国王，最和蔼的国王”。所以这里有一个引人入胜的问题。是什么让他发生了转变？是什么让他成为了国父？我认为，让我们称之为富兰克林的旅程，
from loyalist to radical American patriot, it's also the story of how loyal British colonies come first to resent British rule and then to decide that the best course is to throw it off and declare independence. So he's a kind of very, very representative figure, I think. Well, not least because his lifespan's almost the entire 18th century, doesn't it? So born in 1706, dies in 1788. But I guess the interesting thing about him is that he is looking further back, isn't he? So he's an 18th century figure, but one who is so firmly rooted in the intellectual culture of the 17th century. So there's a sort of element of a flashback to Puritan New England
从保皇派到激进的美国爱国者，这也是忠诚的英国殖民地如何先是开始怨恨英国统治，然后决定最好的办法是摆脱它并宣布独立的故事。所以，我认为他是一个非常有代表性的人物。嗯，不仅因为他的寿命几乎涵盖了整个18世纪，对吧？他生于1706年，卒于1788年。但我猜关于他有趣的一点是，他看得更远，不是吗？他是一个18世纪的人物，但却深深扎根于17世纪的知识文化中。所以，有一种回溯到清教徒新英格兰的感觉，
and to Philadelphia as a Quaker, you know, William Penn and all of that sort of stuff. And Franklin, I guess, to a lot of Americans at the point of his fame, he's a nostalgic relic. Isn't that one of the interesting things about him? As well as being very forward-looking and scientific and all of that stuff. So he belongs to a much older generation than the other three founding fathers that we're talking about in this series. So at the Constitutional Convention in 1787, he's 81 and he is the oldest delegate there by 15 years.
以及作为贵格会教徒的费城，你知道，威廉·佩恩等等。而且富兰克林，我想，对于在他成名时的许多美国人来说，他是一个怀旧的遗迹。这难道不是关于他有趣的事情之一吗？除了非常有远见、科学等等之外。所以他属于比我们在这个系列中谈论的其他三位国父更老的一代。因此，在1787年的制宪会议上，他81岁，是那里最年长的代表，比其他人年长15岁。
So he's twice the age of the average member at this convention. So you're absolutely right. He provides his colleagues with a kind of living link to the very earliest days of America. And I think that is also part of the fascination that in Franklin, you see a guy who is a herald of the American Republic. but he is also a reminder of the kind of the English origins of this republic. So let's begin with beginning with Franklin's parents. And his father, Josiah, had emigrated to Boston in 1683. And he arrives there and he becomes a tallow chandler,
所以他的年龄是这次会议平均年龄的两倍。所以你是完全正确的。他为他的同事们提供了一种与美国最早时期之间的活生生的联系。我认为这也是吸引力的一部分，在富兰克林身上，你看到了一个既是美国共和国先驱的人，但他也是这个共和国英国起源的一种提醒。那么，让我们从富兰克林的父母开始吧。他的父亲约西亚于1683年移民到波士顿。他到达那里后成为了一名牛脂蜡烛商，
which basically means that you render animal fat into candles and soap. And it's very unpleasant, it's very foul smelling, it's very boring work, but it's very, very, very loose. So it's the kind of classic thing that an immigrant would do to kind of set himself up on his own feet. And Josiah had emigrated definitely because he felt that the business opportunities were better in America. But he'd also done it for that classic 17th century reason. He is a Puritan and he wants to practice his religion, as he put it, with freedom. He feels that in the wake of the restoration of Charles II and the restoration of Stuart rule,
这基本上意味着你把动物脂肪提炼成蜡烛和肥皂。这非常令人不快，气味非常难闻，是非常枯燥的工作，但它非常、非常、非常自由。所以这是移民为了自立门户而做的典型事情。约西亚移民绝对是因为他觉得在美国的商业机会更好。但他这样做也是出于那个经典的17世纪原因。他是一名清教徒，他想按照他所说的那样，自由地实践他的宗教。他觉得在查理二世复辟和斯图亚特王朝统治恢复之后，
England doesn't provide him with the opportunities for religious freedom that he knows that Boston and Massachusetts. Massachusetts will do. And this is even truer of Franklin's mother, who's called Abaya, so it's a very Puritan name. And she was the child of Puritans who had emigrated in the 1630s. So that's the decade before, you know, before the English Civil War in the reign of Charles I. So those links, you know, Franklin's grandparents really are taking you back to the kind of the beginnings of Puritan America. So he's surely growing up with stories, you know, story. is about Charles I the First and the Puritans and I don't know they're talking about ship money or something all the time in the Franklin
英国并没有提供他所知道的波士顿和马萨诸塞州所能提供的宗教自由。对于富兰克林的母亲来说更是如此，她叫阿比亚（Abiah），这是一个非常清教徒的名字。她是17世纪30年代移民的清教徒的孩子。所以那是英国内战和查理一世统治之前的十年。所以那些联系，你知道，富兰克林的祖父母真的把你带回了清教徒美国开始的时候。所以他肯定是在关于查理一世和清教徒的故事中长大的，我不知道，他们一直在富兰克林
household which again is a reminder of how the origins of the American War of Independence lie in the politics of 17th century England don't they? Yeah he's growing up in a very very devoutly
家里谈论“船税”之类的东西，这再次提醒我们，美国独立战争的起源在于17世纪英国的政治，不是吗？是的，他在一个非常、非常虔诚的
Puritan household everyone is reading the Bible so he observed later that in New England everybody reads the Bible and is acquainted with scripture phrases and the young
清教徒家庭中长大，每个人都在读《圣经》，所以他后来观察到，在新英格兰，每个人都读《圣经》，并且熟悉经文短语，而年轻的
Benjamin is a very bookish boy as we'll see and he comes to know the Bible backwards. So it's completely, it's there in his head. He is one of 11 siblings and he's the youngest boy and he grows up in a very tiny cramped house in Boston on Milk Street. And today you can go and see the site and there's a kind of very ornate, impressive building with a classical bust and lettering and all kinds of things. This was not at all the vibe of the house that he grew up in
本杰明是一个非常爱读书的男孩，正如我们将要看到的，他把《圣经》背得滚瓜烂熟。所以它完全存在于他的脑海中。他是11个兄弟姐妹中最小的男孩，他在波士顿牛奶街一栋非常狭小拥挤的房子里长大。今天你可以去看看那个遗址，那里有一座非常华丽、令人印象深刻的建筑，有古典半身像、刻字和各种各样的东西。这根本不是他长大的房子的氛围，
because it burnt down, I think, in kind of 1810 or something like that. But back then, it was dirty, it was dingy, there was tallow everywhere, there was soap everywhere, there were candles everywhere. One of Benjamin's elder brothers had drowned in a tub of suds when he was 16 months old before Benjamin had even been born. So it's a kind of, you know, it's pretty dangerous. It's a kind of industrial environment. But because it's industrial, there is industry and there is hard work.
因为我想它在1810年左右被烧毁了。但在当时，那里很脏，很昏暗，到处都是牛脂，到处都是肥皂，到处都是蜡烛。本杰明的一个哥哥在16个月大时，也就是在本杰明出生之前，就淹死在了一桶肥皂水里。所以这是一种，你知道，相当危险的工业环境。但因为它是一个工业环境，所以有勤奋和努力工作。
And there is a commitment to improving yourself and bettering yourself and getting richer. And this also, with the Puritanism, is a massive part of Franklin's inheritance. Well, he loves this, doesn't he? The self-made man. The American story, I mean, Ronald Reagan at this point in heaven is why wiping away tears of treacle. Yeah, and this is a crucial part of how Franklin comes to influence what will become the United States. because the values that Franklin has absorbed from his parents, self-discipline, hard work, prudence, self-reliance, as you said, these enable Franklin to become the prototype of that great American archetype,
并且有一种致力于自我提升、改善自己和变得更富有的承诺。这也与清教主义一起，是富兰克林遗产的重要组成部分。嗯，他喜欢这个，不是吗？白手起家的人。美国故事，我的意思是，罗纳德·里根此时在天堂里正擦去糖浆般的眼泪。是的，这是富兰克林如何影响未来美国的一个关键部分。因为富兰克林从父母那里吸收的价值观——自律、勤奋、审慎、自力更生，正如你所说，这些使富兰克林成为了那个伟大的美国原型——
the self-made man. Franklin is the first, the kind of defining example of this. So in 1758, he gave his personal recipe for getting rich, very famous phrase, the waiter wealth is as plain as the waiter market. It depends chiefly on two words, industry and frugality. So again, that word industry. I mean, the frugality, you know, it's kind of Warren Buffett. He'd be into that.
白手起家的人。富兰克林是第一个，也是定义性的例子。所以1758年，他给出了他致富的个人秘诀，一句非常著名的短语：“致富之路就像通往市场的路一样平坦。它主要取决于两个词：勤奋和节俭。”所以，又是那个词“勤奋”。我的意思是，节俭，你知道，这有点像沃伦·巴菲特。他会喜欢这个。
I mean, probably most of the billionaires today in America wouldn't. But it's an important part, I think, of how billionaires and millionaires have liked to think of themselves as being kind of Benjamin Franklin-esque. Yeah. And he loves a, I mean, one of the things about Benjamin Franklin, that I perhaps find a tiny bit annoying is he loves a folksy maxim. Well, you know why you'd find it annoying. Well, because, I mean, I'll give you one of his foxy maxims. Early to bed and early to rise makes a man healthy, wealthy and wise.
我的意思是，可能今天美国的大多数亿万富翁不会。但我认为，亿万富翁和百万富翁喜欢认为自己是本杰明·富兰克林式的人物，这是很重要的一部分。是的。而且他喜欢，我的意思是，关于本杰明·富兰克林的一件事，我可能觉得有一点点烦人，就是他喜欢民间格言。嗯，你知道为什么你会觉得它烦人。嗯，因为，我的意思是，我会给你一个他的民间格言：“早睡早起使人健康、富有和聪明。”
And we have a kind of ongoing debate, don't we, whether we should start at 8.30 or 9.30. And you're very much a 9.30 man. And I'm very much an 8.30 man. So I've learnt the lessons of Franklin's foxy wisdom. But on the other hand, you go to bed at like 8.30 at night, don't you? or something ridiculous. There are no gains without pains. Have you somewhat to do tomorrow?
我们有一种持续的争论，不是吗，我们应该在8:30还是9:30开始。而你非常倾向于9:30。而我非常倾向于8:30。所以我已经吸取了富兰克林民间智慧的教训。但另一方面，你晚上8:30就上床睡觉了，不是吗？或者类似荒谬的时间。“没有付出就没有收获。”你明天有什么事要做吗？
Do it today. I can absolutely see why you like this play. You think this Blake is absolutely brilliant. So again, he wrote these in 1758. And by this point, I mean, he had kind of lived the life that he was preaching because he'd become the most successful printer in the whole of America, all 13 colonies. And he's become the dominant figure in its newspaper industry. So again, he is the prototype of the kind of the American media mogul.
今天就做吧。我完全明白为什么你喜欢这个家伙。你认为这个家伙绝对是天才。所以，他是在1758年写下这些的。到这个时候，我的意思是，他已经过上了他所宣扬的生活，因为他已经成为了整个美国，所有13个殖民地中最成功的印刷商。而且他已经成为了报业的主导人物。所以，他又是那种美国媒体大亨的原型。
And a bit like Logan Roy in succession. He's done all this with very little formal education, no kind of startup funds. He, you know, his parents are not particularly wealthy. And in fact, Franklin's beginnings had been very kind of brutal because he'd been apprenticed as a printer to his older brother, Jack, in Boston. And he'd essentially found this as being akin to indentured servitude. His brother was a kind of very tough employer. And young Benjamin hated it so much that he ran away to Philadelphia. And he arrived in Philadelphia with only a Dutch dollar, which, who knows what that is.
而且有点像《继承之战》里的洛根·罗伊。他几乎没有受过正规教育，没有任何启动资金，就完成了这一切。他，你知道，他的父母并不是特别富有。事实上，富兰克林的起步非常残酷，因为他被送到波士顿的哥哥杰克那里当印刷学徒。他基本上发现这类似于契约奴役。他的哥哥是一个非常严厉的雇主。年轻的本杰明非常讨厌它，以至于他逃到了费城。他到达费城时只有一枚荷兰硬币，谁知道那是什么。
It doesn't sound good. And he then spent it on three puffy rolls. And this is a very famous scene in his autobiography. Some sort of Dunkin' Donuts scenario. I guess so. And it's famous, I think, this scene because of the contrast. It's kind of almost a Kensian between the kind of the raggedy, starving boy who's fled his master in Boston, come to Philadelphia, he's starving, and the man that he has become by his early
听起来不怎么样。然后他把它花在三个松软的面包卷上。这是他自传中非常著名的一幕。某种唐恩都乐（Dunkin' Donuts）场景。我想是吧。我认为这一幕之所以出名，是因为对比。在那个从波士顿逃离主人的衣衫褴褛、饥肠辘辘的男孩，来到费城，他正在挨饿，和他到40岁出头时已经成为所有13个殖民地中最富有的商人之一的男人之间，有一种几乎是凯恩斯式的对比。富兰克林在他的自传中写下了这个故事，我想，我的意思是，这可能是美国文学的第一部伟大经典。它绝对是一部开创性的自传。在此之前几乎没有什么自传。直到我读到它之前，我并没有真正意识到这一点。所以你有圣奥古斯丁的自传，那是一部著名的。卢梭也会在18世纪写他的自传。但富兰克林的自传早于卢梭的，而且它比奥古斯丁或卢梭的要轻松得多。
40s, one of the wealthiest businessman in all the 13 colonies. And Franklin writes up this story in his autobiography, which is, I guess, I mean, probably the first great classic of American literature. It's certainly an absolutely groundbreaking autobiography. There have been very few autobiographies before this. I hadn't properly realized this until I read up about it. So you had the autobiography of St. Augustine is a kind of famous one. Rousseau will write his autobiography as well in the 18th century. But Franklin's autobiography precedes Rousseau's, and it's much, much less serious than Augustine's or Rousseau's.
所以约翰·厄普代克（John Updike），他是他的忠实粉丝，将其描述为“一部充满欢快矛盾和幽默转折的弹性无忧无虑的作品，是对早期自我的深情回顾，让一个极其雄心勃勃的年轻人受益于老年人的放松”。而任何读过美国小说，更不用说美国自传的人，
So John Updike, who was a big fan, described it as an elastically insuciant work full of cheerful contradictions and humorous twists, a fond look back upon an earlier self, giving an intensely ambitious young man the benefit of the older man's relaxation. and anyone who has read American fiction, let alone American autobiography,
都会认出那种特征。所以这绝对有马克·吐温的影子，我想。我喜欢你在笔记中将他与罗纳德·里根的比较。我的意思是，罗纳德·里根没有写他自己的自传。但如果他写了，也许它会像本杰明·富兰克林的一样，和本杰明·富兰克林的一样好。但在他的演讲中，
will kind of recognize that characteristic. So there's definitely something Mark Twain, I think. I like your comparison in the notes to Ronald Reagan. I mean, Ronald Reagan didn't write his own autobiography. But if he had done, maybe it would have been like Benjamin Franklin, as good as Benjamin Franklin's. But in his speeches,
语气就是富兰克林自传的那种，民间风格，自嘲，但充满了，一种他非常认真对待的信念。这就是富兰克林自传的基调。而且你可以，你知道，它的影响几乎无处不在，我想。两人都有非常虔诚的母亲。这更多的是幽默感。
the tone is that of Franklin's autobiography, kind of folksy, self-mocking, but full of, a kind of conviction that he takes very seriously. And that is the tone of Franklin's autobiography. And you can, you know, its influences is pretty much everywhere, I think. Both had very religious mothers. It's the humor more than anything else.
气质。他阳光且风趣。而且，你知道，里根喜欢开玩笑。我认为富兰克林给他在美国的继承人的是一种感觉，即你可以开个玩笑，而这不会让人们觉得你更差。事实上恰恰相反。我认为这对一个初生的国家来说是一个重要的教训。是的。
Temperament. He's sunny and he is funny. And, you know, Reagan was enjoyed a joke. And I think that what Franklin gave to his heirs in America was the feeling that you could make a joke and it wouldn't make people think the less. of you and in fact quite the opposite. And I think that's an important lesson for an infant country to learn. Yeah.
对于历史播客来说也是如此。确实，是的。所以富兰克林能够写他的自传，并以这种非常有影响力的风格写出来，是因为他已经在几十年里磨练了这种风格，因为除了作为美国领先的出版商，他也是这一时期美国领先的记者。所以在他20多岁和30多岁的时候，他一直在不停地写作，他可以处理绝对任何话题，你知道，对于一个记者来说，这是一种辉煌的品质，
And indeed for history podcasts. Indeed, yes. So Franklin was able to write his autobiography and to kind of write it in these very, very influential style because he had honed that style over several decades because as well as being America's leading publisher, he is also America's leading journalist in this period. So throughout his 20s and 30s, he was writing not. on stop and he could turn his hand to absolutely any topic, you know, brilliant kind of quality
并且以一种如此引人入胜和独特的方式写下这些各种各样的话题，以至于他的风格在13个殖民地再次变得完全可辨认。所以，到他40岁时，如果你读到富兰克林写的东西，而你不知道是他写的，你会立即认出它。这再次成为一个对于将要成为革命宣传家的人来说非常有用的技能。人们熟悉他的基调，熟悉他的方法和态度。基本上，它包括用机智、讽刺、寓言来包装一种说教的基调。而这，再次，我认为，是美国公共生活的一种非常
for a journalist to have and write about, you know, these various topics in such an engaging and distinctive manner that his style became completely recognisable again across the 13 colonies. So again, by the time he is 40, if you read something that Franklin has written and you don't know that he'd written it, you would recognise it immediately. And that again is a kind of incredibly useful skill for someone who's, you know, going to become a propagandist for a revolution. People are familiar with his tone, with his kind of approach and his attitude. And basically, it consists of sugaring a kind of moralizing tone with wit, with satire, with parable. And that, again, I think, is a kind of very
典型的品质，说教，但民间化。是的，非常、非常、非常、非常像雷根。是的，寓言，小轶事和故事。而富兰克林结合了什么，所以说教是其中一个严肃的部分，不是吗？所以如果我们只谈论焦点和糖衣，我们就错过了一些关于富兰克林的东西，那就是有一个绝对严肃的道德核心，我猜最终源于清教徒。是的。所以这就是与17世纪的联系。那种童年的清教主义，他从父母那里继承的对勤奋和节俭的强调，
characteristic quality of American public life, moralizing, but foxy. Yeah, very, very, very, very raking. Yeah, parables, little anecdotes and stories. And what Franklin combines, so that So the moralism is as a serious part of it, isn't it? So if we just talk about the focus on us and the sugar, we miss something about Franklin, which is there is an absolutely serious moral core that I guess derives ultimately from the Puritans. Yeah. So this is the link back to the kind of the 17th century. That childhood Puritanism, the emphasis that he had inherited from his parents on industry and frugality
以及在自己的职业中勤奋等等，它是宗教启发的。它是清教徒式的，并且在20世纪初被一位名叫马克斯·韦伯（Max Weber）的德国作家的一部关于这个主题的伟大经典所著名地强调，他写了一本书《新教伦理与资本主义精神》。韦伯对富兰克林如何能够假设他所宣扬的关于勤奋、节俭等的必要性的道德是理所当然的这个问题很着迷。他是如何能够假设这实际上是道德的？而韦伯的回答是，他在自传中用《圣经》中的一句话回答了这个问题，这是他严厉的清教徒父亲在他年轻时一遍又一遍地灌输给他的。
and diligence in one's calling and all of that, it is. kind of religiously inspired. It is Puritan and it was famously highlighted in early 20th century by the great classic on this topic by a German writer called Max Weber, who wrote a book The Protestant Ethic and the Spirit of Capitalism. And Weber was fascinated by the question of how it was that Franklin was able to assume that the morality that he was preaching about the need for diligence, for frugality and so on. How is he able to assume that this was actually? How is he able to assume that this was actually moral. And Weber's answer is, he answers in his autobiography with a quotation from the Bible, which his strict Puritan father drummed into him again and again in his youth.
“你看见办事勤奋的人吗？他必站在君王面前。”这是《箴言》中的一句话。所以这是一个非常、非常基督教的教训，一个清教徒的教训。但与此同时，是什么让富兰克林关于这一点的说教对18世纪的非清教徒美国人如此有吸引力，而且在18世纪，许多美国人开始摆脱清教主义，即使在马萨诸塞州也是如此，那就是它实际上根本没有任何真正的公开的基督教色彩。关于富兰克林的民间风格、道德主义和教义的隐性基督教特征，有一本精彩的书，作者叫托马斯·基德（Thomas Kidd），《本杰明·富兰克林：一位国父的宗教生活》。基德的论点，
Seest thou a man diligent in his business, he shall stand before kings. And that is a quote from the book of Proverbs. So it's a very, very Christian lesson, a Puritan lesson. But at the same time, what makes Franklin's moralizing about this so appealing to non-Puritan Americans in the 18th century, and in the 18th century, lots of Americans are starting to move on from the Puritanism, even in Massachusetts, is that there isn't actually kind of any real overt Christianity in it at all. And there is a brilliant book on this, on the kind of occludedly Christian character of Franklin's folksiness and moralism and teachings by a guy called Thomas Kid, Benjamin Franklin, the religious life of a founding father. And kids' argument,
本质上是，富兰克林确实仍然与他在这个清教徒家庭中作为孩子所采用的教义保持联系。但他已经厌倦了清教徒对教条、正统和对圣经教义细节的奉献的强调。他真的不太喜欢那个。他是一个更广泛的人。他想要强调爱、慈善、对全人类的服务。所以托马斯·基德写道，富兰克林本质上是一个实验者，他修补了一种新颖的
essentially, is that Franklin does remain tethered to the teachings that he's adopted as a child in this Puritan household. But he had wearied of the kind of the Puritan emphasis on doctrine and orthodoxy and devotion to the specifics of biblical teaching. He's not really really into that. He's a much kind of broad brush guy. He wants emphasis on love, on charity, on service to all of mankind. So Thomas Kidd writes, Franklin was an experimenter at heart and he tinkered with a novel
基督教形式，一种几乎所有信仰都变得非本质的形式。这非常受欢迎，因为它使美国人能够保留他们那种基本的基督教信念，而不必担心教义的细节，甚至不必特别去教堂。托马斯·基德难道没有一个极好的迹象表明，本杰明的继承人，
form of Christianity, one where virtually all beliefs become non-essential. And this is hugely popular because it enables Americans to retain their kind of gut Christian convictions without having to worry about the details of doctrine or indeed even having to with going to church particularly. And doesn't Thomas' kid have an excellent sign that the air to Benjamin,
在这方面本杰明·富兰克林的真正继承人实际上是奥普拉·温弗瑞（Oprah Winfrey）。是的。因为奥普拉·温弗瑞所做的一切都是关于……善良。是的，善良。哈里王子会喜欢这一切的。是的。嗯，我的意思是，我认为这是一种基督教形式，
the true heir to Benjamin Franklin in this regard is actually Oprah Winfrey. Yes. Because Oprah Winfrey is all about... Kindness. Yeah, kindness. Prince Harry would love all this. Yes. Well, I mean, I think that it's a form of Christianity
它是美国和更广泛的西方数百万人的默认模式。而且富兰克林，正如基德所说，是一个修补匠。稍微有点怀疑论，但当然在当时可能不被视为稍微模糊、松散和感性，而是实际上被视为怀疑论和自由思想的标志，并且非常符合启蒙运动的情绪，我猜。是的，所以这是富兰克林的另一个方面，他因此而闻名，即使他在散布这种后清教徒式的民间道德，
that it's the default mode of millions of millions of people in America and the West more generally. And Franklin is, as kids says, are a kind of tinkerer. slightly come by R, but of course at the time perceived probably not as a slightly vague, woolly and touchy-feely, but actually as a sign of skepticism and free thinking and very much of the mood of the Enlightenment, I guess. Yes, so this is the other kind of aspect of Franklin for which he becomes famous, is that even as he is dispensing this kind of post-Puritan folksy morality,
他也能够展示自己，因为他不是以公开的基督教术语说话，而是作为启蒙运动的象征性人物，在他一生中，在欧洲和越来越多的美国，启蒙运动正在席卷那个时代的顶级知识分子。所以1757年，富兰克林跨越大西洋，在英国度过了五年。甚至在他离开之前，他就已经被欧洲顶级思想家非常、非常认真地对待了，达到了以前没有任何美国人在欧洲被认真对待的程度。所以1759年他去了苏格兰，他住在爱丁堡，你知道，北方的雅典。
he is also able to present himself because he's not talking in overtly Christian terms, terms as a kind of an emblematic figure of the Enlightenment, which over the course of his life in Europe and increasingly in America is kind of sweeping the top intellectuals of the age. So in 1757, Franklin crosses the Atlantic for what is going to turn out to be a five-year stay in Britain. Even before he leaves, he has already been taken very, very seriously by top European thinkers to a degree that no American had been taken seriously before in Europe. So in 1759 he goes to Scotland and he stays in Edinburgh, you know, the Athens of the North.
这是苏格兰启蒙运动的黄金时代。他会见了戴维·休谟（David Hume），他真的是他那个时代最伟大的哲学家。休谟和富兰克林相处得非常好。他们举行了一次很棒的晚宴。他们都享受生活。他们都是享乐主义者。之后，休谟写信给富兰克林，他说：“美国送给我们许多好东西，黄金、白银、糖、烟草、靛蓝，但你是我们所亏欠她的第一位哲学家，也是第一位伟大的文学家。”
This is the golden age of the Scottish Enlightenment. And he meets with David Hume, who is the greatest philosopher of his age, really. And Hume and Franklin get on tremendously well. They have a kind of great dinner party. They both enjoy life. They're both bonfever. And after it, Hume writes to Franklin and he says, America has sent us many good things, gold, silver, sugar, tobacco, indigo, but you are the first philosopher and indeed the first great man of letters for whom we are beholden to her.
是的，我认为那是真的，不是吗？富兰克林是北美殖民地产生的第一个真正国际级的知识分子。这不仅是因为他在说，你知道，不要浪费，不要想要，无论他在这些有趣的寓言中写什么。而且还因为他做了另一件我们余生都非常钦佩的事情。他正在推动科学的前沿。他是，但更具体地说，他进行了整个18世纪最引起共鸣的科学实验。
Yeah, and I think that's true, isn't it? Franklin is the first genuinely international class intellectual that the North American colonists have produced. And this is not just because he's saying, you know, waste not want that, whatever he's writing in these entertaining parables. but it's also because he does something else that we're massive admirers of for the rest of history. He's pushing back the frontiers of science. He is, but more specifically, he has conducted the single most resonant scientific experiment
所以理查德·罗宾逊（Richard Robinson），一本关于启蒙运动的精彩新书的作者，将这个实验描述为启蒙运动及其将人类从不必要的恐惧中解放出来的项目的伟大象征性时刻。这个实验发生在1752年6月的费城，当时富兰克林，在他的幸存儿子，一个叫威廉的年轻人的帮助下，带着风筝走进了一场雷雨，他在阵风中放飞了这个风筝。
of the whole of the 18th century. So Richard Robinson, author of a brilliant recent book on The Enlightenment, describes this experiment as the great symbolic moment for the Enlightenment and for its project of freeing humanity from needless terrors. And this experiment had occurred in June 1752 in Philadelphia when Franklin, who is helped by his only surviving son, a young man called William, had gone out into a thunderstorm with a kite and he had flown this kite in the kind of the gusting of the winds.
在这个风筝上，他连接了一根尖锐的金属丝。这反过来，当它升入天空，进入风中时，成功地从云层中引出了电火花。富兰克林由此得出结论，从而证明了电物质与闪电的同一性。所以这同时，嗯，取决于你如何看待它，这是一个非常有前瞻性的实验。它是勇敢的。它也是极其鲁莽的。如果一个英国议会选区的17岁男孩做了这件事，《每日快报》（Daily Express）上会有一篇关于国家青年智力堕落的两页报道，不是吗？是的，嗯，顶级书呆子电死儿子之类的。
And this kite he had attached a kind of sharp wire to its end. And this in turn, as it went up into the sky, into the winds, had succeeded in drawing electric sparks from a cloud. And Franklin drew the conclusion from this, thereby the sameness of electrical matter with that of lightning, was completely demonstrated. So this is simultaneously, well, depending on how you perceive it, it is a very forward-thinking experiment. It is courageous. It's also a criminally reckless. If a 17-year-old boy on a British councillor state did this, there'd be a two-page story in the Daily Express about the debasement of intellect among the nation's youth or something, wouldn't it? Yeah, well, the top egghead electrocute son or something.
是的，完全正确。是的，我的意思是，你说它很危险。所以富兰克林做这个实验一年后，一个俄国人试图复制它，结果被电死。我的意思是，我不应该笑，但这极其危险。但它有巨大的后果。首先，它证明了所有关于宙斯发送闪电作为众神愤怒的表达之类的东西，这都是胡说八道。这是一种物理现象。
Yeah, exactly. Yeah, I mean, you say it's dangerous. So a year after Franklin did this experiment, a Russian tried to replicate it, I'm going to electrocuted and killed. I mean, I shouldn't laugh, but it is exceedingly dangerous. But it has massive consequences. So first of all, it proves that all this stuff about Z. sending lightning as the expression of the wrath of the gods or whatever, that this is nonsense. It is a physical phenomenon.
终于，那个长期存在的问题得到了解决。嗯，人们，这对我是个启示。17世纪的人们走来走去说，宙斯真的在扔雷电吗？肯定不是吧。嗯，让我们说，只要人类在地球上，就一直有人担心这是众神愤怒的表达之类的。我的意思是，并非所有人都像你那样对物理科学知识有复杂的了解。我的意思是，你必须接受这一点。
Finally, that long-running question has been solved. Well, people, this is a revelation to me. The people in the 17th century walking around saying is you really throwing thunderbolts? Surely not. Well, let's say that for as long as humans have been on the planet, there have been those who have feared that it is an expression of the anger of the gods or whatever. I mean, not all of them have your sophisticated relationship to knowledge of physical sciences. I mean, that has to be, you have to accept that.
不，他们很公平，是的。但它也有非常实际的后果。这不仅仅是关于，你知道，为了知识而知识。所以富兰克林让费城的人们在城市的高层建筑上安装避雷针。好的，我有一个问题。是的。为了什么目的？因为避雷针会吸引闪电并将其传导下去。
No, they're fair, yeah. But it also has very practical consequences. This isn't just about, you know, knowledge for knowledge sake. So Franklin gets the people of Philadelphia to put lightning rods on the high buildings of the city. Okay, I've got a question. Yeah. To what end? Because the lightning rods will attract the lightning and run it down.
出于某种原因，电流会被分散，它不会点燃教堂之类的东西。那是对的吗？它真的是那样工作的吗？这基本上就是它的工作方式。如果有顶级避雷针分析师在听这个，也许他们可以扩展一下。我知道你会问我那个问题。我想我已经给出了大致的要点。
And for some reason, the electricity will be dispersed and it won't set the churches on fire or whatever. Is that right? Does that really how it works? That is basically how it works. If we have top lightning rod analysts listening to this, perhaps they can expand. I knew you were going to ask me that question. I think I've kind of given the rough gist of it.
基本上，避雷针是有效的。这就是你需要记住的全部。它们做了一些事情，这很棒。每个人都喜欢它。但同样，关于富兰克林非常令人印象深刻的事情是，即使他发明了这些避雷针，他也没有申请专利，因为他希望每个人都能使用它。去做点什么。
Basically, lightning rods work. This is all you need to keep in mind. They do something and that's brilliant. And everyone loves it. But also the thing that's very impressive about Franklin is that even though he's invented these lightning rods, he doesn't put a patent on it because he wants everybody to be able to use it. To do something.
没人知道它是什么，但他们会用这些避雷针做点什么。它会阻止闪电击中建筑物引发火灾，在一个大多数建筑物都是木制的时期，他正在造福人类。所以汤姆，你对避雷针赞不绝口，但我会说它扮演了一个次要的角色，考虑到这是一个发明了手持脚蹼的人。那是一个更……？嗯，你说，男人，他是在他还是个孩子，还是个男孩的时候做的。我的意思是，我认为这令人难以置信地印象深刻。所以跟我说说脚蹼。
No one knows what it is, but they'll do something with these lightning rods. It will stop lightning strikes on buildings starting fires, which in a period where most buildings are made of wood, he is benefiting humanity. So Tom, you rave about the lightning rod, but I would say that plays very much a secondary role, given that this is a man who's invented the handheld flipper. Is that a more? Well, you say, man, he did it when he was a child, when he was a boy. I mean, I think that's incredibly impressive. So talk me through the flippers.
我会说通常你会在脚上穿脚蹼。我的意思是，我当然不会穿脚蹼。他从手上的脚蹼开始。它让他加速，然后他也尝试在脚上穿。所以基本上他发明了一个脚蹼。他还发明了天气预报，我认为这确实非常令人印象深刻。他是通过分析东海岸风暴的移动来做到这一点的。这与锋面之类的有关。
I would say normally you wear a flipper on your foot. I mean, I don't wear flippers as a matter, of course. He begins with flippers on his hands. It speeds him up, and then he tries them on the feet as well. So basically he invents a flipper. He also invents weather forecasting, which I think is genuinely very impressive. And he'd done this by analysing the movement of East Coast storms. And it was something about fronts or whatever.
再次，不太清楚细节。但他发明了天气预报。所以把它记在账上。而且众所周知，他发明了双焦眼镜，他在1784年相当晚的时候才做这件事。所以如果你在戏剧或电影中看到富兰克林，他总是会戴着他的双焦眼镜。他还，只是为了好玩，他识别并命名了墨西哥湾流。太棒了。
Again, quite know the details. But he invents weather forecasting. So put that in the ledger. And famously, he invents bifocal glasses, which he does quite late in 1784. So if you ever see Franklin in a kind of play or a film or something, he will always be wearing his bifocal spectacles. He also, just for good measure, he identifies maps and names the Gulf Stream. Brilliant.
再说一次，我不太了解细节。但他发明了天气预报。所以把这一点记在账上。还有众所周知的是，他在1784年晚些时候发明了双焦眼镜。所以如果你在戏剧或电影中看到富兰克林，他总是戴着双焦眼镜。此外，为了保险起见，他还绘制并命名了墨西哥湾流。真是太棒了。
Love the Gulf Stream. You know, the dream of warm water that keeps Britain free of sub-zero temperatures. And when he's in Britain, he goes for a walk on Clapham Common, which is, I should think, a mile and a half from where I'm sitting right now. and it's very stormy and there's a pond in Clapham Common and it's very rough and he plays a tremendous
热爱墨西哥湾暖流。你知道，那种让英国免于零下低温的温暖水域的梦想。当他在英国时，他会去克拉珀姆公地散步，我想，离我现在坐的地方大约有一英里半远。那里风雨交加，克拉珀姆公地有一个池塘，水面非常汹涌，他玩了一个了不起的
trick to impress the people he's walking with he takes out a little flask of oil and he pours oil on it and I'm going to quote from my notes here he thereby demonstrates the existence of what will subsequently be termed surface tension and for those of us not as clued up as you are
把戏来打动和他一起散步的人，他拿出一个小油瓶，把油倒在水面上，我要引用我的笔记了，他由此证明了后来被称为表面张力的现象的存在，对于我们这些不像你那么了解的人来说
like how does that work exactly well oil Dominic as you will know spreads on water until it's only one molecule thick and it therefore demonstrates how molecules interact with the surface of a liquid. Correct. I hoped you'd say that
比如那到底是怎么运作的？嗯，多米尼克，正如你所知，油在水面上扩散，直到只有一层分子那么厚，因此它展示了分子是如何与液体表面相互作用的。没错。我希望你会这么说
and you did. Because I didn't want to do a podcast for somebody who didn't know. So anyway, you think he's brilliant. You think he's Leonardo da Vinci basically? No, I don't think he's Leonardo because in a sense this is all actually quite kind of second division stuff. But he is seen by his peers
你确实说了。因为我不想为一个不懂的人做播客。总之，你认为他很聪明。你基本上认为他是列奥纳多·达·芬奇？不，我不认为他是列奥纳多，因为从某种意义上说，这实际上都是些二流的东西。但他被他的同僚们视为
in the 18th century as basically being the Leonardo of the Enlightenment. You think the flipper of the lightning rod and the oil on troubled waters is second division. I think the lightning rod is impressive. But I think when it comes to kind of inventing and scientific breakthroughs and stuff, he's too foxy. It's all about flippers. All this stuff makes him famous. And he's, listen, I have never invented a lightning rod or anything.
在18世纪，他基本上被视为启蒙运动的列奥纳多。你认为避雷针的发明者和“平息风浪的油”是二流的。我认为避雷针令人印象深刻。但我认为当谈到发明和科学突破之类的东西时，他太狡猾了。这全都是关于脚蹼。所有这些东西让他出名。而且，听着，我从来没有发明过避雷针之类的东西。
So who am I to criticise him? It's the kind of stuff that you would get in a science's fun book aimed at eight-year-old. Totally. It's so BBC 2. It's BBC 2, 8 o'clock. It's 1986. it's some wacky science program presented by a comedian. Blue Peter.
所以我有什么资格批评他呢？这就像是那种针对八岁儿童的趣味科学书里的内容。完全正确。这太BBC 2了。这是BBC 2，晚上8点。那是1986年。这是一个由喜剧演员主持的古怪科学节目。蓝色彼得节目。
Exactly. For children. So that's the kind of level he's operating, but that's the kind of level, you know, that kind of appeals. You can turn your cardboard box into a hovercraft. That's Benjamin Franklin's vibe. And I think also that it is a kind of very British vibe. This is the kind of stuff that everyone in Britain is doing at this time as well. You know, it's tinkering, kind of inventing steam engines and things like that.
正是如此。给孩子们看的。所以这就是他所处的水平，但这也是那种，你知道，那种吸引人的水平。你可以把你的纸箱变成气垫船。这就是本杰明·富兰克林的风格。而且我认为这确实是一种非常英国的风格。这也是当时英国每个人都在做的事情。你知道，就是修修补补，发明蒸汽机之类的东西。
And so when Franklin comes to Britain, they welcome him. as one of his own. And he's in Britain a lot. So between 1757 and 1775, he spends 16 years in all in the very centre of things in a house just off what is now Trafalgar Square, so by Whitehall. And this is a house on Craven Street, and it's the only surviving house where Franklin stayed. You can go and see it. It's well worth a visit. And I think he's such a celebrity, particularly in Britain, but also in France, as we will see and further afield, that he comes to have a huge impact on how America is seen. And because he has this status as an inventor of flippers and lightning rods or whatever, it helps him to brand the new world not as a kind of dumping ground for mad religious zealots, almost as the opposite, as a kind of laboratory of the future, you know, a testing ground for the Enlightenment. And even before he's arrived, people have been putting lightning rods up on some of the most famous buildings.
所以当富兰克林来到英国时，他们欢迎他，把他当作自己人。他在英国待了很长时间。所以在1757年到1775年之间，他总共在伦敦市中心的一所房子里住了16年，就在现在的特拉法加广场附近，靠近白厅。这是克雷文街上的一所房子，也是富兰克林住过的唯一幸存的房子。你可以去参观一下。非常值得一去。我认为他是一位名人，特别是在英国，但也像我们将要看到的那样，在法国以及更远的地方，他对于美国如何被看待产生了巨大的影响。因为他拥有发明脚蹼和避雷针之类的身份，这有助于他将新世界塑造为不是那种疯狂宗教狂热分子的倾倒场，几乎恰恰相反，而是作为一种未来的实验室，你知道，启蒙运动的试验场。甚至在他到达之前，人们就已经在一些最著名的建筑上安装了避雷针。
in London. So St. Paul's has got one, St. James's Palace. So he's, you know, he's much, much admired. He's also brilliant at portraying himself and by extension America as a kind of antidote to flummery and hierarchy and pretension and snobbery. And this again is going to be a theme of America's relationship to the old world, that America is a frontier society. People are somehow nobler, better, simpler there. And a. Again, Franklin is the guy who really kind of brands this. He's the guy who initiates this whole kind of comparison. So even though he's not a Quaker, he dresses like one.
在伦敦。所以圣保罗大教堂有一个，圣詹姆斯宫也有。所以他，你知道，他非常非常受人钦佩。他也非常擅长塑造自己，进而将美国塑造为一种对抗浮夸、等级制度、虚伪和势利的反毒药。这再次成为美国与旧世界关系的一个主题，即美国是一个边疆社会。那里的人们在某种程度上更高尚、更好、更简单。而且，富兰克林再次成为了真正塑造这一形象的人。他是发起这种比较的人。所以尽管他不是贵格会教徒，但他穿得像个贵格会教徒。
People in Britain are very respectful of Quakers. They like that. So Franklin is very self-consciously kind of plugging into that image. He gets elected a member of the Royal Society, the great scientific community that Newton and everybody he belonged to. And he casts himself as a member of the Royal Society's belonging to the true aristocracy of the Enlightenment. is much better than being a Duke or something.
英国人非常尊重贵格会教徒。他们喜欢那样。所以富兰克林非常自觉地在利用那种形象。他当选为皇家学会的成员，那是牛顿和所有他所属的伟大科学团体。他把自己塑造成皇家学会的一员，属于启蒙运动真正的贵族。这比当公爵之类的要好得多。
And again, he kind of weaponises, I think, in an overtly performative way, a kind of eccentricity. He becomes well known in London for his air baths, he calls them, which involves every, he gets up in the morning, he opens all his windows, he sits on the side of his bed without any clothes at all, so the great rolls of his belly kind of flummering over his knees. And he'll sit there for half an hour, whatever the season, whether it's summer or whether the snow is gusting in, and he sees this as being good for his health. Do you know who would really approve of this? A new producer, Callum Hill, because he was telling me last week that he goes,
而且，我认为他以一种公开表演的方式，将某种怪癖武器化了。他在伦敦因他的“空气浴”而闻名，他称之为空气浴，这包括每天早上他起床，打开所有的窗户，赤身裸体地坐在床边，他肚子上的大褶皱垂在膝盖上。无论什么季节，无论是夏天还是雪花飘进来，他都会在那里坐上半个小时，他认为这对他的健康有好处。你知道谁会真正赞同这一点吗？我们的新制片人卡勒姆·希尔，因为他上周告诉我，他去
he's gone all these foreign trips where he strips off naked and jumps into like pools and baths and stuff. Well, Turkey, Finland, all of this. I think he's not wrong. Because if you think how long Franklin lived. Japan, he did it in Japan. He's written in the chat. Callum's like stripped off in countries all over the world. I mean, if Callum lives as long as Benjamin Franklin, he'll have done well.
他去了所有这些外国旅行，在那里他脱光衣服跳进池塘和浴缸之类的东西里。嗯，土耳其、芬兰，所有这些。我认为他没错。因为如果你想想富兰克林活了多久。日本，他在日本也这么做了。他在聊天记录里写了。卡勒姆在世界各地的国家都脱光过衣服。我的意思是，如果卡勒姆能活得像本杰明·富兰克林那么久，那他就很不错了。
Also, similar. it. Callum always wears flippers on his hands. All the time. It's an eccentricity, isn't it? Now, Dominic, it has to be said that although there are lots of people in Britain who love all this, there are also lots of people who hate it. And they mistrust Franklin and his kind of enlightenment posing as atheistical, as seditious, as threatening to the established order. Now we're talking. They too, a bit like you, despise his folkishiness.
而且，类似。卡勒姆总是戴着脚蹼。一直戴着。这是一种怪癖，不是吗？现在，多米尼克，必须说，虽然英国有很多人喜欢这一切，但也有很多人讨厌它。他们不信任富兰克林和他那种启蒙运动的姿态，认为那是无神论的、煽动性的，是对既定秩序的威胁。现在我们说到点子上了。他们也和你有点像，鄙视他的平民气息。
as kind of provincial and rustic and a bit cringe, I think. And Tom, among their number of critics and skeptics, is there the greatest man in history? Yes, Samuel Johnson, Dr. Johnson. He views everything about Franklin as just the rankest hypocrisy. Now, it's interesting. They are kind of the Lions of London at the same time. As far as we know, they never met,
认为那是乡土气、粗野，而且有点令人尴尬。汤姆，在这些批评者和怀疑者中，有历史上最伟大的人吗？是的，塞缪尔·约翰逊，约翰逊博士。他认为关于富兰克林的每一件事都只是最彻底的虚伪。现在，这很有趣。他们同时是伦敦的“狮子”。据我们所知，他们从未见过面，
although James Boswell, who is Samuel Johnson's biographer, did meet Franklin and got on well with him. but I think the fact that Johnson and Franklin never met, it's a kind of known unknown. The reason that they don't meet, I suspect, is precisely because they're so keen not to meet. They are very hostile to each other's principles. But also, is it not that basically they are, the room isn't big enough for both of them? That they, you know, they're both got their ex-interestists. They're both incredibly clever.
尽管塞缪尔·约翰逊的传记作者詹姆斯·鲍斯威尔确实见过富兰克林，并且和他相处得很好。但我认为约翰逊和富兰克林从未见过面的事实，是一个所谓的“已知的未知”。我怀疑他们没有见面的原因，恰恰是因为他们非常不想见面。他们对彼此的原则非常敌视。但还有，难道不是因为基本上他们，房间容不下他们两个人吗？他们都有自己的利益。他们都极其聪明。
They're both the centre of the show, the centre of attention. they're like two successful podcasters on rival goalhanger podcasts. You can't be brought into the same room. Except for the fact that there is a very specific point, ideological point of difference between them. And this is the topic of slavery. So Dr. Johnson was, he was very hostile to Americans as a matter of principle. And he was particularly hostile to the claim that Americans had to be fonder of liberty than people in Britain. And he famously wrote of the War of Independence, how is it that we hear the loudest yelps for liberty among the drivers of Negroes?
他们都是节目的中心，关注的焦点。他们就像两个在竞争对手Goalhanger播客上的成功播客主。你不能把他们带进同一个房间。除了一个事实，那就是他们之间有一个非常具体的意识形态分歧点。这就是奴隶制的话题。所以约翰逊博士，他原则上非常敌视美国人。他特别敌视美国人比英国人更热爱自由的说法。他曾写下关于独立战争的名言：“为什么我们在黑奴的驱赶者中听到了最响亮的自由呼声？”
And Franklin had brought with him to London two slaves. One of these slaves had then absconded and Franklin had composed an advert that he wanted to put in the papers requesting the slaves' return. He then thought better of it. I think because he could, you know, he was nervous for being accused of hypocrisy. But it didn't stop him in 1770 from writing an anonymous defense of slavery that I think is probably the lowest point in his career. And 1770 is the year in which he also wrote that parable about the English Mastiff and the Lion Club. And it was prompted by growing tensions between the British government and the American colonies. And Franklin's own despair at the thought of where these tensions might lead.
富兰克林曾带了两个奴隶到伦敦。其中一个奴隶后来逃跑了，富兰克林写了一则广告，想登在报纸上要求找回奴隶。后来他觉得不妥。我想是因为他，你知道，他担心被指责为虚伪。但这并没有阻止他在1770年写下一篇匿名的奴隶制辩护文章，我认为这可能是他职业生涯的最低点。1770年也是他写下关于英国獒犬和狮子幼崽那则寓言的一年。这是由英国政府和美国殖民地之间日益紧张的关系所引发的。富兰克林自己对这些紧张局势可能导致的后果感到绝望。
So he wrote, being born and bred in one of the countries and having lived long and made many agreeable connections in the other, I wish all prosperity to both. And his instinct throughout this period of growing tension between Britain and the American colonies is always to call for civility and good manners and essentially to behave as he had behaved on Clapham Common to pour oil on troubled waters. But the problem for Franklin, he's by this point been in London for so long that he is essentially, he's kind of lost touch with the growing mood of radicalism on the other side of the Atlantic. And he's failed to realize how far he's lagging behind this mood of radicalism. And that means that, you know, he is going to have to wise up. And the point is approaching essentially where he is going to have to decide where his loyalties lie. Do they lie with Britain or do they lie with the colonies back in America? So Franklin has an excruciating choice to make and he'll be making that choice after the break.
所以他写道：“出生并成长于其中一个国家，并在另一个国家生活了很长时间并建立了许多愉快的联系，我祝愿两者都繁荣昌盛。”在英国和美国殖民地之间紧张局势加剧的整个时期，他的本能总是呼吁文明和礼貌，本质上表现得就像他在克拉珀姆公地上表现的那样，去平息风浪。但富兰克林的问题在于，他此时在伦敦待的时间太长了，以至于他基本上已经与大西洋彼岸日益增长的激进情绪脱节了。他没有意识到自己落后于这种激进情绪有多远。这意味着，你知道，他将不得不变得聪明起来。本质上，他将不得不决定自己的忠诚在哪里，这一点正在临近。他们是忠于英国，还是忠于美国的殖民地？所以富兰克林面临着一个极其痛苦的选择，他将在休息后做出那个选择。
The bloody struggle will end an absolute slavery to America or ruined to Britain by the loss of her colonies. So welcome back to The Rest is History. Top flipper enthusiast and defender of slavery, Benjamin Franklin, is still, hoping that he can somehow bridge the gap between Parliament in London and the militant separatists in New England. So it's December 1772 and he has been leaked. He's been given some letters. They've been written by the governor of Massachusetts, Thomas Hutchinson. So Tom, tell me about these letters.
“血腥的斗争将以美国的绝对奴役或英国因失去殖民地而毁灭告终。”欢迎回到《历史的真相》。顶级脚蹼爱好者和奴隶制捍卫者本杰明·富兰克林，仍然希望他能以某种方式弥合伦敦议会与新英格兰激进分裂分子之间的鸿沟。现在是1772年12月，他收到了一些泄露的信件。这些信是由马萨诸塞州州长托马斯·哈钦森写的。所以汤姆，告诉我关于这些信的事。
So in these letters, Hutchinson has been advising the British government on how best to cool the colonial unrest. in America, and he writes and says, there must be an abridgment of what are called English liberties. And these are the liberties that the colonists in Massachusetts are asserting against the demands of the British government for taxes and other such similar goods. And Franklin's Wees, when he's got these letters, he is going to now leak them in turn to the radicals in Boston. And his reason for doing this isn't to cause trouble for the British government, but the absolute opposite. He wants to demonstrate to the radicals
在这些信中，哈钦森一直在建议英国政府如何最好地平息美国的殖民地动荡。他写道，必须缩减所谓的“英国自由”。这些正是马萨诸塞州的殖民者针对英国政府对税收和其他类似商品的要求所主张的自由。当富兰克林拿到这些信时，他现在要转而把它们泄露给波士顿的激进分子。他这样做并不是为了给英国政府制造麻烦，而是恰恰相反。他想向激进分子证明
that the British government is pursuing a hard line, not because the British despise the Americans as, you know, colonials, but because they are receiving terrible advice from people like Hutchinson. In other words, if they can just be educated, then the British will start behaving well and stop demanding taxes. But the whole thing, you know, this whole wheeves goes terribly wrong because, you know, this is an example of how Franklin doesn't recognise what's going on now in Boston,
英国政府采取强硬路线，不是因为英国人鄙视美国人，你知道，作为殖民地人，而是因为他们从像哈钦森这样的人那里收到了糟糕的建议。换句话说，如果他们能被教育，那么英国人就会开始表现良好，停止要求税收。但整件事，你知道，整个诡计出了大问题，因为，你知道，这是一个例子，说明富兰克林没有意识到波士顿现在正在发生什么，
the radicals there completely ignore Franklin's direct request to them not to publicise Hutchinson's letters. They immediately publish them and make a massive, massive song and dance about them. And there's a huge blowback in London about this, and Franklin
那里的激进分子完全无视富兰克林直接要求他们不要公开哈钦森信件的请求。他们立即发表了这些信件，并围绕它们大做文章。这在伦敦引起了巨大的反弹，富兰克林
ends up being summoned to appear before the Privy Council in the tremendously named Cockpit, and it's called that because it's a room in Whitehall where Henry the 8th supposedly had staged cockfights. But Franklin goes there, and he finds it's more like bull baiting or something. Everyone has gathered there to take down the representative of the Upperti Colonials.
最终被传唤到枢密院面前，地点在名字极其响亮的“斗鸡场”，之所以叫这个名字，是因为它是白厅的一个房间，据说亨利八世曾在这里举办过斗鸡比赛。但富兰克林去了那里，发现它更像是斗牛之类的东西。每个人都聚集在那里，要打倒这个傲慢的殖民地代表。
And Franklin himself put it, all the courtiers were invited as to an entertainment. Everyone there is keen to see him savaged. And he is savaged. Paul Franklin, he's there dressed in a blue Manchester velvet coat and he's described as standing conspicuously erect without the smallest movement of any part of his body.
正如富兰克林自己所说，所有的朝臣都被邀请来观看一场娱乐活动。那里的每个人都渴望看到他被撕碎。他确实被撕碎了。可怜的富兰克林，他穿着一件蓝色曼彻斯特天鹅绒外套，被描述为站得笔直，身体的任何部分都没有丝毫移动。
But for all that, he is absolutely torn to pieces. And he is produced, not just for his role in having made Hutchinson's letters public, even though he hadn't wanted this to happen, but as a kind of uppity treasonous colonial. And there is such fury. And he is the object of this kind of venomous fury, I think because the Boston Tea Party has just happened. So just the month before.
但尽管如此，他还是被彻底撕成了碎片。他被指控的不仅仅是因为他让哈钦森的信件公开，尽管他并不希望这种情况发生，而是作为一个傲慢的叛国殖民者。而且有如此大的愤怒。他是这种恶毒愤怒的对象，我认为是因为波士顿倾茶事件刚刚发生。就在一个月前。
and the mood in London against the Americans as a result is very angry, very, very embittered. And Franklin, because he's actually in the capital, because he is the most famous American, almost the kind of the representative American, and because after all, he had actually leaked the Hutchinson letters, it doesn't matter what his motives are if you're in the British government. I mean, he is the guy who's let's slit these secrets. You know, he provides the perfect scapegoat. Right. And just to remind especially British listeners, the Boston Tea Party is when basically a load of Americans who are angry about the monopoly. It's a monopoly on tea, isn't there? And they're very cross about it and they throw a load of tea into the harbour. Ecological vandalism. Yes, and they dress up as Native Americans. Terrible cultural appropriation. Shocking. It's a bad business, however you look at it. And Franklin agrees. This is the irony of the whole situation. So he had described the Boston Tea Party as an act of violent injustice on our part. But,
因此，伦敦对美国人的情绪非常愤怒，非常非常痛苦。而富兰克林，因为他实际上就在首都，因为他是最著名的美国人，几乎是那种代表性的美国人，而且毕竟，他确实泄露了哈钦森的信件，如果你在英国政府里，他的动机是什么并不重要。我的意思是，他是那个泄露这些秘密的人。你知道，他提供了完美的替罪羊。没错。为了提醒英国听众，波士顿倾茶事件是指基本上很多对垄断感到愤怒的美国人。这是一种茶叶垄断，不是吗？他们对此非常生气，于是把一大堆茶叶扔进了港口。生态破坏行为。是的，他们还打扮成美洲原住民。可怕的文化挪用。令人震惊。无论你怎么看，这都是一件坏事。富兰克林也同意。这就是整个情况的讽刺之处。所以他曾将波士顿倾茶事件描述为“我们这一方的暴力不公正行为”。但是，
Franklin's experience in the cockpit will help him to make up his mind, this invidious choice he has. He's sympathetic both to Britain and to the colonists. But he sees his own experience at the cockpit as an indication of the fact that Britain is lurching into tyranny and repression, just as the kind of the radicals back in Boston are saying. In other words, Franklin's take is that he hasn't changed. It's Britain that has changed. He still lingers in London even after coming to this decision, kind of desperately trying to work with those in the British elite
富兰克林在斗鸡场的经历将帮助他下定决心，做出这个令人不快的选择。他既同情英国，也同情殖民者。但他将自己在斗鸡场的经历视为英国正在陷入暴政和压迫的迹象，正如波士顿的激进分子所说的那样。换句话说，富兰克林的看法是他没有变。是英国变了。即使在做出这个决定后，他仍然留在伦敦，试图与英国精英中那些同情美国愿望的人合作。但到了1775年，他受够了。他放弃了。他于3月20日永远离开了英国。他从朴茨茅斯乘邮船前往宾夕法尼亚。作为典型的富兰克林，当他在海上时，他忙于每天测量三四次墨西哥湾暖流的温度，为他的理论提供科学支持。
who are sympathetic to American aspirations. But by 1775 he's had enough. He throws his hands up. And he leaves Britain forever on the 20th of March. He set sail from Portsmouth on a packet ship bound for Pennsylvania. And typically being Franklin while he's at sea, he busies himself by measuring the temperatures of the Gulf Stream three or four times a day, providing the scientific backing for his theory.
（注：原文此处索引跳跃，根据内容逻辑衔接）
And while he is doing that in America, open hostilities are breaking out. So by the time Franklin lands in Philadelphia on the 5th of May, the shot heard around the world has been fired at Lexington Green, British Redcoats and colonial militia are at war outside Boston. And so when Franklin lands in Philadelphia, to pass. Patriotic Americans, this is a tremendous moment. The world's most famous American has landed, it seems, in the nick of time, to provide their cause with the kind of prestige and authority that it so desperately needs.
当他在海上做这些事时，美国爆发了公开的敌对行动。所以当富兰克林在5月5日抵达费城时，“震惊世界的一枪”已经在列克星敦绿地打响，英国红衫军和殖民地民兵在波士顿外开战。所以当富兰克林抵达费城时，对于爱国美国人来说，这是一个了不起的时刻。世界上最著名的美国人似乎及时赶到了，为他们的事业提供了他们迫切需要的声望和权威。
Well, they're just about to open the Continental Congress, aren't they? So they've summoned all these delegates from the 13 rebel colonies. And the Continental Congress is going to end up being, what did I describe it as? the last episode, the political wing of the insurgency. And for Franklin to have turned up a bloke who, you know, he's very famous across the world, he knows about Europe, doesn't he, in European affairs. And I guess also precisely because he hasn't been a militant until now, that makes him a great asset to their cause.
嗯，他们正要召开大陆会议，不是吗？所以他们召集了所有来自13个反叛殖民地的代表。大陆会议最终将成为，我在上一集里是怎么描述它的？叛乱的政治分支。对于富兰克林来说，他是一个在全世界都非常出名的人，他了解欧洲，不是吗，了解欧洲事务。而且我想也正是因为他直到现在都不是一个激进分子，这使他成为他们事业的一大资产。
Yes, absolutely. And so a reporter is sent down to the docks to interview Franklin. And he writes that Franklin thinks nothing else can save us from the most abject slavery in destruction. So Franklin has essentially kind of made his decision. And so it's not surprising that the moment he's back, he's chosen by the Pennsylvania Assembly to be one of their delegates to the Continental Congress. And because he is Benjamin Franklin, because everybody knows he's brilliant at organizing things. He's a great guy for showing initiative. he gets appointed to a kind of insane number of committees.
是的，绝对是。所以一名记者被派往码头采访富兰克林。他写道，富兰克林认为“没有什么能把我们从最卑微的奴役和毁灭中拯救出来”。所以富兰克林基本上已经做出了决定。所以他一回来就被宾夕法尼亚议会选为大陆会议的代表之一，这并不奇怪。而且因为他是本杰明·富兰克林，因为每个人都知道他擅长组织事情。他是一个展现主动性的好手。他被任命进入了数量惊人的委员会。
So he's set to organising the infant American postal system. You did a documentary, didn't you, once for Radio 4 about the postal system? So he's very like you. He loves the postal system. We're very similar. And it's not surprising because it's been estimated that over the course of his life, Franklin Central received some 15,000 letters. So if you're doing that, you need a good functioning post office.
所以他被安排组织初生的美国邮政系统。你曾经为第四电台做过一部关于邮政系统的纪录片，不是吗？所以他和你很像。他热爱邮政系统。我们非常相似。这并不奇怪，因为据估计，在他的一生中，富兰克林收到了大约15,000封信。所以如果你要处理这些，你需要一个运作良好的邮局。
and he will actually end up the first postmaster general of the United States. He's also set to organising the military supplies to Washington. And remember he'd done this already before in the Seven Years' War. And most importantly of all, he is co-opted to help draft one last appeal to George III. And this will become known as the Olive Branch petition. So basically saying, yeah, come on, George, give us what we want and then we won't rebel. But actually, even while he's working on this, Franklin has already made up his mind. And he thinks, you know, there's no option.
他最终将成为美国第一任邮政总长。他还被安排组织对华盛顿的军事补给。记住他在七年战争中已经做过这件事了。最重要的是，他被拉拢去帮助起草最后一份给乔治三世的呼吁书。这就是后来被称为“橄榄枝请愿书”的文件。所以基本上是说，是的，来吧，乔治，给我们想要的，然后我们就不会反叛。但实际上，即使在他写这份文件时，富兰克林也已经下定决心了。他认为，你知道，没有别的选择了。
The breach with Britain is irreparable. It's got to be war. And he knows that this is going to cost him because his son, William, the boy who had helped him with his flying kite experiment, he has become the governor of New Jersey on behalf of the British Crown. And he is a very committed loyalist. He's one of those, you know, many, many people in America who back what Parliament is doing. And William rides from New York to try and persuade his father to remain, you know, neutral, if you know, if you can't side with Britain, at least stay neutral. But Franklin is having
与英国的决裂是不可挽回的。必须是战争。他知道这将让他付出代价，因为他的儿子威廉，那个曾帮他做风筝实验的男孩，已经代表英国王室成为了新泽西州的州长。他是一个非常坚定的保皇党。他是那些，你知道，美国许多许多支持议会所作所为的人之一。威廉从纽约骑马赶来，试图说服他的父亲保持，你知道，中立，如果你，如果你不能站在英国一边，至少保持中立。但富兰克林根本不听。
none of it. And he tells William very flatly, I am now in favour of independence. And father and son have to accept that they are now the other's enemy. And there's the breach between them, you know, as between Britain and America, the breach between Franklin and his son is going to prove irreparable. It's never, never healed. And Franklin wants to illustrate this for his friends in Britain. He wants them to know that he has made his mind up. And this is partly, I think, to counter the sense that the radicals in the Congress have that he is, you know, he's famously an anglophile. So they're, they're suspicious of him. They think that perhaps he's, you know, he's secretly a British agent. But it is also an attempt to sway those in the Congress who are nervous of declaring
他直截了当地告诉威廉：“我现在支持独立。”父子俩不得不接受他们现在是对方的敌人。他们之间的决裂，你知道，就像英国和美国之间一样，富兰克林和他儿子之间的决裂将被证明是不可挽回的。它永远永远没有愈合。富兰克林想向他在英国的朋友们说明这一点。他想让他们知道他已经下定决心了。这在一定程度上，我认为，是为了反击国会中的激进分子认为他，你知道，他是一个著名的亲英派。所以他们，他们怀疑他。他们认为也许他，你知道，他私下里是英国特工。但这也是为了动摇国会中那些害怕宣布
independence. He wants to kind of, you know, apply all his prestige and status to the cause of, declaring independence. So on the 5th of July, which is two and a half weeks after Bunkers Hill in Boston, a very kind of bloody battle, the olive branch petition is formally adopted by Congress. So they still haven't given up. They still want to give the British one last chance. And Franklin had voted for it, but he wanted to indicate to everybody in America that he didn't really back it.
独立的人。他想，你知道，运用他所有的声望和地位来支持宣布独立的事业。所以7月5日，也就是波士顿邦克山战役（一场非常血腥的战斗）两周半后，橄榄枝请愿书被国会正式采纳。所以他们仍然没有放弃。他们仍然想给英国最后一次机会。富兰克林投了赞成票，但他想向美国的每个人表明他并不真正支持它。
So this is kind of very, very recognizable political technique, isn't it? politicians who are bound, say, by cabinet, collective responsibility will leak something. Tony Ben enters the chat. Yeah. So Franklin, he pulls this trick by writing a public letter to an old friend in London who was a printer called William Strahan. So Franklin himself had been a printer. And Franklin addresses this friend of his with very icy formality.
所以这是一种非常非常可识别的政治技巧，不是吗？受内阁集体责任约束的政客会泄露一些东西。托尼·本加入了聊天。是的。所以富兰克林，他通过写一封公开信给伦敦的一位老朋友（一位名叫威廉·斯特拉汉的印刷商）来玩这个把戏。所以富兰克林本人也曾是一名印刷商。富兰克林以非常冰冷的礼节称呼他的这位朋友。
So he calls him Mr. Strahan. And Franklin wrote, you are a member of parliament. And one of that majority which has doomed my country to destruction. have begun to burn our towns and murder our people. Look upon your hands. They are stained with the blood of your relations. You and I were long friends. You are now my enemy and I am yours, be Franklin. And it's a very famous letter. And it's famous because rather than actually sending it to Strahan, Franklin instead circulated it among his fellow members of Congress as a way of stiffening their resolve. So it's just a PR exercise. He never actually sends it.
所以他称他为“斯特拉汉先生”。富兰克林写道：“你是议会的一员。是那个注定要毁灭我国家的多数派中的一员。你们已经开始烧毁我们的城镇，谋杀我们的人民。看看你们的手。它们沾满了你们亲人的鲜血。你我曾是长期的朋友。你现在是我的敌人，我是你的，本·富兰克林。”这是一封非常有名的信。它之所以出名，是因为富兰克林并没有真正把它寄给斯特拉汉，而是把它在国会同事中传阅，作为一种坚定他们决心的方式。所以这只是一个公关练习。他实际上从未寄出过它。
It's completely a PR exercise. And actually, he and Strahan remained great friends. And when in due course, Franklin goes to France, Strahan sent him a lovely cheese. All right. The Declaration of Independence, that doesn't take place until the following year, 1776, hence the 250th anniversary this year.
这完全是一个公关练习。事实上，他和斯特拉汉仍然是好朋友。当富兰克林后来去法国时，斯特拉汉还送了他一块可爱的奶酪。好吧。《独立宣言》，那要到第二年，即1776年才发生，因此今年是250周年纪念。
And Franklin is part of the committee charge of drafting it, but he actually leaves most of the writing to Thomas Jefferson, doesn't he? Yeah, that's partly because he's got a very bad attack of boils at this point. And bad attacks of boils. A feature. Well, it's not an aspect of the founding fathers that gets a lot of attention, I think, in America, but it will on our podcast. Franklin gets bad boils a lot. But I think it's also because he can recognize that Jefferson's prose is perhaps better suited to the kind of elevated tone that the Declaration of Independence needs than his own kind of folksy Christmas Cracker Maxim's.
富兰克林是负责起草它的委员会成员，但他实际上把大部分写作工作留给了托马斯·杰斐逊，不是吗？是的，这部分是因为他当时患有严重的疖子。严重的疖子。一个特征。嗯，这不是开国元勋中在美国受到很多关注的一个方面，但我认为在我们的播客上会。富兰克林经常长严重的疖子。但我认为这也是因为他能认识到，杰斐逊的散文可能比他自己那种平民化的圣诞拉炮格言更适合《独立宣言》所需要的崇高基调。
But he does make one very famous edit to Jefferson's first drone. So Jefferson has written the phrase, We hold these truths to be sacred and undeniable, and Franklin crosses out the last three words and changes it to we hold these truths to be self-evident. And I guess it's a kind of classic example of what had been Franklin's lifelong project as a moralist, which is to veil the assumptions that had derived from his Christian upbringing
但他确实对杰斐逊的初稿做了一个非常著名的修改。杰斐逊写了这样一句话：“我们认为这些真理是神圣且不可否认的”，富兰克林划掉了最后三个词，改成了“我们认为这些真理是不言而喻的”。我想这是一个经典的例子，说明了富兰克林作为道德家终生的项目，那就是掩盖那些源于他基督教教养的假设
behind the pretense that they were somehow objective and derived from reason. And of course, the notion that these rights are self-evident has been hugely influential. And people still believe it to this day. So the Declaration of Independence is presented to the Congress and it's adopted. The die is cast. The Rubicon is crossed. And on the 2nd of August, the Declaration is formally signed by the members of the Congress, including Benjamin Franklin, and it's President John Hancock. He adds his signature
在它们在某种程度上是客观且源于理性的伪装之下。当然，这些权利是不言而喻的这一概念影响深远。人们至今仍然相信这一点。所以《独立宣言》被提交给国会并被采纳。大局已定。卢比孔河已经跨越。8月2日，宣言由国会成员正式签署，包括本杰明·富兰克林，主席是约翰·汉考克。他加上了他的签名
to it, then declares solemnly, there must be no pulling different ways. We must all hang together. And Franklin makes a famous reply, yes, we must indeed all hang together, almost assuredly, we shall all hang separately, because of course they are now traitors in the eyes of the British Crown, and that will be their fate if they are captured. And we talked in the previous episode, didn't we, about the American strategy, about the fact that basically it's a little bit like Vietnam. They basically have to stay in the game, avoid a pitch battle, hope that the British, you know, struggling to subdue or to impose themselves on the vast canvas of the North American continent will eventually lose heart and be sick of throwing money into this down the drain
然后庄严地宣布：“我们不能各行其是。我们必须团结一致。”富兰克林做出了著名的回答：“是的，我们确实必须团结一致，否则我们几乎肯定会分别被绞死。”因为当然，在英国王室眼中，他们现在是叛徒，如果被俘，这就是他们的命运。我们在上一集里谈到了美国的战略，关于事实上这有点像越南。他们基本上必须留在游戏中，避免正面交锋，希望英国人，你知道，在努力征服或将自己强加于北美大陆的广阔画布上时，最终会失去信心，厌倦了把钱扔进这个无底洞
and will give up. But obviously, what the Americans want above all is they want some form of European intervention. I mean, you think you were implying in the previous episode, they didn't really have a prospect of winning unless they could get that backing. The might of the British Empire is so huge that they will lose without it. And so the obvious person to try to get this, I suppose, is the most famous living American, and that's Benjamin Franklin. Correct. And this is why, on the 26th of October 1776, so three months after, you know, he and the other delegates have signed the Declaration of Independence, he boards this American sleep of war called the reprisal, and he sets sail back across the Atlantic, but this time he is heading not for Britain, but for France. And Franklin will end up
并放弃。但显然，美国人最想要的是某种形式的欧洲干预。我的意思是，你似乎在上一集里暗示，除非他们能得到那种支持，否则他们真的没有获胜的前景。大英帝国的力量如此巨大，没有它他们就会输。所以尝试获得这个支持的显而易见的人，我想，就是最著名的在世美国人，那就是本杰明·富兰克林。没错。这就是为什么在1776年10月26日，也就是他和国会其他代表签署《独立宣言》三个月后，他登上了这艘名为“报复号”的美国单桅战船，再次横渡大西洋，但这一次他不是前往英国，而是前往法国。富兰克林最终将
spending nine years there as America's first ambassador to a foreign power. And in that time, back in his homeland, as we heard in our previous episode, you know, battles or, as you put it, skirmishes will rage, cities will burn. Franklin's own house in Philadelphia will be occupied and converted into a British billet. And at the time and ever since, Franklin's Sojourn in France amid the flesh pots of Auxien Regime, Paris, has been cast as a kind of episode of high comedy and as a dereliction of duty. So Woody Holton in Liberty is Sweet, who doesn't agree with that characterization, he caricatures it as one long flirtation with female aristocrats.
在那里度过九年，作为美国驻外国的第一任大使。在那段时间里，回到他的祖国，正如我们在上一集里听到的那样，你知道，战斗或者，正如你所说的，小规模冲突将肆虐，城市将燃烧。富兰克林在费城的家将被占领并改建为英国人的驻地。当时以及此后，富兰克林在法国旧制度巴黎的肉欲之地中的逗留，一直被描绘成一场闹剧，一种玩忽职守。所以伍迪·霍尔顿在《自由是甜的》中，不同意这种描述，他将其讽刺为与女性贵族的一场漫长的调情。
And Franklin's friend in London, Edmund Burke, great philosopher and politician, and the man who had been perhaps his most formidable ally in the British establishment, he went so far as to condemn Franklin for a foul and dishonorable flight. But I think that is a mad judgment on Franklin, because to make a winter crossing, which is what Franklin was doing to get to France,
富兰克林在伦敦的朋友，伟大的哲学家和政治家埃德蒙·伯克，那个可能曾是他英国建制派中最强大的盟友的人，甚至谴责富兰克林进行了“卑鄙且不光彩的逃亡”。但我认为这对富兰克林来说是一个疯狂的判断，因为进行一次冬季横渡，这正是富兰克林为了去法国所做的，
at the age of 70, you know, the conditions were so rough that Franklin said they almost demolished him across an ocean controlled by the Royal Navy. I mean, the fact that Britain rules the waves is part of what Franklin is going to France to try and upend. I mean, this is not the action of a
在70岁的时候，你知道，条件非常恶劣，以至于富兰克林说他们差点让他垮掉，穿越一个由皇家海军控制的海洋。我的意思是，英国统治海洋的事实正是富兰克林去法国试图颠覆的一部分。我的意思是，这不是一个
coward. Franklin is an incredibly brave and resolute man. But when he gets to France, he does rather enjoy the flirtation of a female aristocrats, no? Of course he does. Of course he does. I mean, Franklin is a man who does not see enjoying yourself as a
懦夫的行为。富兰克林是一个极其勇敢和坚决的人。但当他到达法国时，他确实很享受与女性贵族的调情，不是吗？他当然享受。他当然享受。我的意思是，富兰克林是一个不认为享受生活是
sin. I mean, you know, to that extent he has set his childhood puritanism behind him. And, you know, as we've said, he's gone there because he's a celebrity. And so he can say, well, it's my patriotic duty to behave like a celebrity. He plays it up massively. And he has a complete genius for it because he is, he understands the roles that the French public want him to play. He is familiar with the casts of thought in the Enlightenment. So this is the age of Rousseau. And Rousseau identifies virtue and liberty with the primitive beginnings of humanity. And so Franklin, whenever he goes to court, makes sure to wear a kind of frontiersman's fur cap, like kind of Davy Crockett or something.
罪的人。我的意思是，你知道，在某种程度上，他已经把童年的清教徒主义抛在脑后了。而且，正如我们所说，他去那里是因为他是一个名人。所以他可以说，表现得像个名人是我的爱国义务。他极大地发挥了这一点。他对此有着完全的天才，因为他理解法国公众希望他扮演的角色。他熟悉启蒙运动的思想流派。所以这是卢梭的时代。卢梭将美德和自由与人类的原始开端联系起来。所以富兰克林每次去宫廷时，都会确保戴上一顶边疆人的皮帽，就像戴维·克罗克特之类的。
Oh, God, almighty. Imagine that at the court of Louis the 16th or whatever. You know, they're all wearing their wigs, you know, their kind of powdered wigs. And Franklin is turning up with this fur cap. It's a massive fashion statement. And I don't forget his flippers. Plunching into the fountains of Versailles. So that's kind of playing to fans of Rousseau.
哦，天哪。想象一下在路易十六的宫廷里那样。你知道，他们都戴着假发，你知道，那种扑粉的假发。而富兰克林戴着这顶皮帽出现。这是一个巨大的时尚宣言。而且别忘了他的脚蹼。跳进凡尔赛的喷泉里。所以这有点迎合卢梭的粉丝。
This is also the age of Voltaire, the kind of feline, witty, enlightened champion of reason. And Franklin, this is the man who has tamed lightning, who has redeemed humanity from the superstition of fear. And again, Franklin is the guy to cast. himself and America as a kind of embodiment of a new enlightened future. So in 1778, he has two massively histrionic meetings with Voltaire. In the first occasion, Voltaire lays his hands on the head of Franklin's grandson, who has come with Franklin to France, and declares in English, good and liberty, and everybody huzzars and bursts tears and its absolute scenes. And then the second, they have a meeting, at the Academy Royal
这也是伏尔泰的时代，那种猫一样的、机智的、开明的理性捍卫者。而富兰克林，这个人驯服了闪电，将人类从恐惧的迷信中拯救出来。同样，富兰克林是塑造自己和美国成为一种新的开明未来的化身的人。所以在1778年，他与伏尔泰进行了两次极其戏剧性的会面。在第一次场合，伏尔泰把手放在富兰克林孙子的头上（他随富兰克林来到法国），并用英语宣布：“上帝与自由”，每个人都欢呼并热泪盈眶，场面绝对感人。然后第二次，他们在皇家科学院会面
and the two men embrace and they are described by one observer as being like so long embracing Sophically so the two great sages of ancient Greece and again everyone not a dry eye in the house. So this plays tremendously well to
两人拥抱，被一位观察者描述为“像古希腊的两位圣贤拥抱”。同样，每个人都热泪盈眶。所以这非常迎合
the kind of the intellectual gallery the gallery of the kind of ministers who will be deciding whether America is worth investing in. Now at the same time he is definitely flirting with female aristocrats and he is definitely enjoying it. I think in his sexual ethics, he remains a Puritan. As a young man, we haven't talked about his marriage up to now. You said that Martha Washington was the most
那种知识分子画廊，那种将决定美国是否值得投资的部长们的画廊。现在，与此同时，他绝对是在和女性贵族调情，而且他绝对很享受。我认为在他的性道德方面，他仍然是一个清教徒。作为一个年轻人，我们到现在还没谈过他的婚姻。你说玛莎·华盛顿是历史上最
boring woman in history. I think that Franklin's wife, what is it about American women? She was a very frugal and incredibly boring widow. I called Deborah Reed. And Franklin had essentially only married her as a way of taming his sexual appetites. She's not a laugh and she's not a great romance. And the evidence for this is that he had not taken her with him to London. He'd refused to return to Philadelphia in 1774, even though by this point he decided that he was on the American side and she was dying. William, his son kept saying, you've got to come back. He doesn't. He can't be bothered with her. And she actually died three months before he left England. So he's really not interested in that. What Franklin is interested in,
无聊的女人。我认为富兰克林的妻子，美国女人是怎么回事？她是一个非常节俭且极其无聊的寡妇。我叫黛博拉·里德。富兰克林基本上娶她只是为了驯服他的性欲。她不是个有趣的人，也不是一段伟大的浪漫史。证据就是他没有带她去伦敦。他在1774年拒绝回到费城，尽管此时他已经决定站在美国这一边，而她快要死了。威廉，他的儿子一直说，你必须回来。他不回来。他懒得理她。她实际上在他离开英国前三个月就去世了。所以他真的对那个不感兴趣。富兰克林感兴趣的是，
What he likes doing is to hang out with very posh, very pretty girls in salons. And it's kind of, it's half flirtation. It's half kind of playing the jovial father figure. And he'd done this in London and now he's in Paris. He does it again. And they all absolutely adore him. But this isn't just self-indulgent because it is also prompted by calculation. Because again, salons like hanging out with Voltaire,
他喜欢做的是在沙龙里和非常时髦、非常漂亮的女孩混在一起。这有点，一半是调情。一半是扮演快乐的父亲形象。他在伦敦做过这个，现在他在巴黎。他又做了一次。她们都绝对崇拜他。但这不仅仅是自我放纵，因为它也是出于计算。因为同样，沙龙喜欢和伏尔泰混在一起，
is a way to raise his credit among the circles of those who matter. Franklin's mission in Paris is very, very simple. He has to secure military, financial backing from the French government for the cause of American independence. And this is actually a huge challenge because France, at the beginning of the war, is not at war with Britain. Two countries at peace, France had had a terrible bruising in the Seven Years' War, hugely in debt. And everyone in Paris assumes, well, the British are bound to win. You know, the Americans are rubbish. But gradually, the tide of war starts to turn.
是提升他在重要人物圈子中信誉的一种方式。富兰克林在巴黎的任务非常、非常简单。他必须为美国独立事业争取法国政府的军事和财政支持。这实际上是一个巨大的挑战，因为在战争初期，法国并没有与英国交战。两国处于和平状态，法国在七年战争中遭受了惨痛的打击，背负着巨额债务。巴黎的每个人都认为，英国注定会赢。你知道，美国人是垃圾。但渐渐地，战争的局势开始转变。
And Franklin, because he has made himself the toast of Versailles and a French public opinion of Voltaire, of all these aristocrats, they all love him as well as admire him. He is perfectly placed to press the advantage and in due course the French do enter the war. And when Franklin goes to sign the Treaty of Alliance, he does so wearing the blue velvet coat that he had worn at the cockpit when the British establishment had torn him to pieces. and he was asked why he had worn this coat, and he answered, to give it a little revenge. And revenge is what he gets, because as we described in the previous episode, France's entry into the war does tip the balance. And when in 1783, the British finally agree terms with their rebellious colonies, they agree to recognise American independence. It is Franklin who has led the negotiations, and it is Franklin who signs what comes to be known as the Treaty of Paris.
而富兰克林，因为他让自己成为了凡尔赛宫的宠儿，成为了伏尔泰和所有这些贵族心目中的法国舆论焦点，他们不仅钦佩他，也喜爱他。他处于绝佳的位置来施加影响，最终法国确实加入了战争。当富兰克林去签署《同盟条约》时，他穿着他在驾驶舱（Cockpit）时穿的那件蓝色天鹅绒外套，当时英国当权派曾对他进行过猛烈抨击。有人问他为什么要穿这件外套，他回答说，为了报一点仇。而他确实得到了报复，因为正如我们在上一集所描述的那样，法国参战确实打破了平衡。当1783年英国最终与他们叛乱的殖民地达成协议时，他们同意承认美国的独立。是富兰克林领导了谈判，也是富兰克林签署了后来被称为《巴黎条约》的文件。
And this has been described by the great American historian, Edmund Morgan, as the greatest diplomatic victory the United States has ever achieved. I don't know whether you'd agree with that, but I mean, it was, you know, an incredible achievement. Well, because it's essential to their independence. Of course, the great irony of this is the Franklin who's been hanging out at Versailles and going to all these salons and enjoying the charms of the posh pretty French ladies. By securing French agreement to that alliance, he has also signed the death warrant
这被伟大的美国历史学家埃德蒙·摩根描述为美国有史以来取得的最伟大的外交胜利。我不知道你是否同意这一点，但我的意思是，这确实是一个令人难以置信的成就。嗯，因为这对他们的独立至关重要。当然，这其中最大的讽刺是，一直在凡尔赛宫流连忘返、出入各种沙龙、享受着时髦漂亮的法国女士魅力的富兰克林，在争取法国同意结盟的同时，也签署了死刑判决书
of the Anzine regime and the French monarchy and Louis XVIth of Marianne. The irony. Yes, there is that consolation for British listeners to bear in mind. This will have disastrous consequences for the French, and that's the important thing. So that is Franklin's term in France. It's highly successful.
针对的是旧制度、法国君主制以及路易十六和玛丽·安托瓦内特。真是讽刺。是的，英国听众可以记住这一点作为安慰。这对法国人来说将产生灾难性的后果，这才是重点。所以这就是富兰克林在法国的任期。它是非常成功的。
And when he returns from France in 1785, it is to a hero's welcome. So he lands in Philadelphia and there are Hazars and Cannon Fire and church bells and all of that. But he still has one last charge to meet, one last celebrated document to sign. And this, of course, is going to be the Constitution. So Franklin, by this point, he is 79 years old. He is a very tired man. He is ill.
当他在1785年从法国回来时，受到的是英雄般的欢迎。他抵达费城，那里有欢呼声、礼炮声、教堂钟声等等。但他还有最后一项任务要完成，最后一份著名的文件要签署。这当然就是宪法。所以富兰克林此时已经79岁了。他是一个非常疲惫的人。他病了。
He can barely walk. But of course, by this point, it's his very age, which means. makes him so valuable to the infant state. He serves them as a kind of living symbol of what America had been, has become, and might yet be. And two years later, when a constitutional convention meets in Philadelphia to determine what form of government the newly independent American state should have, Franklin is, you know, he's in his 80s by now. He's not in any condition to do any of the heavy lifting, but his kind of very presence is a kind of a blessing, a kind of benediction. And I think above all, he embodies the spirit of kind of reaching after
他几乎无法行走。但当然，在这一点上，正是他的高龄使他对于这个新生国家如此宝贵。他作为一种活生生的象征，代表了美国曾经是什么、已经变成了什么，以及未来可能成为什么。两年后，当制宪会议在费城召开以确定新独立的美国应采取何种政府形式时，富兰克林已经80多岁了。他已经没有体力承担任何繁重的工作，但他的存在本身就是一种祝福，一种祈祷。我认为最重要的是，他体现了一种追求
truth, which all his life he had believed was the surest way for people and indeed states to secure life and liberty and happiness. So his house is a surest way. So his house is a sure. short walk away from the State House where the delegates are deciding the constitution. And he has a lovely garden. And this provides a refuge from all the heat and anger and turmoil of the convention. And it's a place where delegates can go to cool down to sit beneath the mulberry tree in his garden and to hammer out compromises. And Franklin himself, you know, he makes occasional addresses to the convention, not many.
真理的精神，他一生都相信这是人民乃至国家确保生命、自由和幸福的最可靠途径。所以他的房子离代表们决定宪法的议会大厦只有很短的步行路程。他有一个可爱的花园。这为会议的所有炎热、愤怒和动荡提供了一个避难所。这是一个代表们可以去冷静下来、坐在他花园里的桑树下并敲定妥协方案的地方。而富兰克林本人，你知道，他偶尔会在会议上发表讲话，次数不多。
But when he makes these addresses, what he has to. has to say is the perfect embodiment of the kind of the fusion between Christian and Enlightenment thinking that I think so characterizes the American Revolution. So he appeals to reason, you know, that's the Enlightenment aspect, but also to the Father of Lights, as he called it, to illuminate our understanding. He's a big enthusiast for starting sessions with prayers, for instance. And when finally on the 17th September 1787, the Constitution of the United States is finally endorsed, it is Franklin who gives the most resonant and memorable speech. He acknowledges that this constitution has imperfections, but he urges his fellow delegates to sign it anyway. I can
但当他发表这些讲话时，他所说的话完美体现了基督教思想与启蒙思想的融合，我认为这正是美国革命的特征。所以他诉诸理性，你知道，那是启蒙运动的一面，但也诉诸他所称的“光明之父”，以照亮我们的理解。例如，他非常热衷于以祈祷开始会议。当1787年9月17日美国宪法最终获得通过时，是富兰克林发表了最响亮、最令人难忘的演讲。他承认这部宪法有缺陷，但他敦促他的代表同僚们无论如何都要签署它。我可以
censor to this constitution because I expect no better and because I am not sure that it is not the best. And in my opinion, if there has to be a revolution, this is the spirit in which revolution should be attempted. And I think it makes Franklin, frankly, my favourite revolutionary. Who wouldn't prefer that kind of spirit of pragmatic compromise to the white-hot certainty
同意这部宪法，因为我不期待更好的，而且我不确定它不是最好的。在我看来，如果必须有一场革命，这就是应该尝试革命的精神。我认为这让富兰克林坦率地成为了我最喜欢的革命者。谁不会更喜欢那种务实妥协的精神，而不是那种炽热的确定性呢？
of a Cromwell or a Robespierre or a Lenin? I think that's a bit harsh on all of a Cromwell, frankly. I think Cromwell is more full of self-doubt than Robespier and Lennon. Yes, but I think Cromwell did things that Franklin would not have countered It was more robust, there's no question. I like the lack of robustness in that phrase.
像克伦威尔、罗伯斯庇尔或列宁那样？我觉得这对克伦威尔有点苛刻，坦率地说。我认为克伦威尔比罗伯斯庇尔和列宁更充满自我怀疑。是的，但我认为克伦威尔做了一些富兰克林不会做的事情。毫无疑问，这更强硬。我喜欢那个短语中缺乏强硬的感觉。
I am not sure that it is not the best. Right. Fine. I think more politicians should say that. I think we'd all be happy. I'll be very clear about this, Tom. I think that this is not the... I mean, you know, if you want to be pragmatic,
我不确定它不是最好的。对。很好。我认为更多的政治家应该这样说。我想我们都会很高兴。关于这一点，汤姆，我要说得很清楚。我认为这不是……我的意思是，你知道，如果你想务实，
if you want to be a person of compromise, and I think compromise is always a good thing. Yeah. You know, say it. But I think also the other great thing about Franklin and why I find him a kind of really admirable person is that he is always alert to the possibility that you might be wrong. Yes, very attractive quality.
如果你想成为一个善于妥协的人，而且我认为妥协总是一件好事。是的。你知道，说出来吧。但我认为富兰克林另一个伟大的地方，以及为什么我发现他是一个真正令人钦佩的人，是因为他总是警惕自己可能会犯错的可能性。是的，非常有吸引力的品质。
That you might need to change your mind. I mean, that is what had brought him from being a great enthusiast for the relationship with Britain to deciding that, no, you know, it's got to go. We need independence. And it's also what brings him in February 1790, so by which point he is 84 years old, to present a very startling petition to call. Congress. And remember, Franklin had been a slave owner, and this one-time slave owner, he no longer
你可能需要改变主意。我的意思是，这就是他从一个与英国关系的狂热支持者转变为决定“不，你知道，这必须结束。我们需要独立”的原因。这也是他在1790年2月，也就是他84岁时，向国会提交一份非常令人震惊的请愿书的原因。记住，富兰克林曾经是一个奴隶主，而这个曾经的奴隶主，他不再
has slaves by this point. He urges Congress to bestow the enjoyment of happiness on all the peoples of the United States and to grant, and I quote, liberty to those unhappy men who alone in this land of freedom are degraded into perpetual bondage. And the petition is rejected, but Franklin does not give up. And one month later, he publishes, I think, a brilliant satire, a satire that is clearly derived from Jonathan Swift, the greatest of all satirists. And he He writes under the pseudonym of Sidi Mehmet Ibrahim and he deploys the same arguments that he being used by anti-ablishists in America to justify the enslavement of Africans, to defend the enslavement of Europeans by the Barbary states of North Africa.
在这一点上拥有奴隶了。他敦促国会赋予美国所有人民享受幸福的权利，并授予，我引用，“给予那些不幸的人自由，他们是这片自由土地上唯一被贬为永久奴役的人。”请愿书被拒绝了，但富兰克林没有放弃。一个月后，他发表了一篇我认为非常精彩的讽刺文章，这篇讽刺文章显然源自所有讽刺作家中最伟大的乔纳森·斯威夫特。他以西迪·穆罕默德·易卜拉欣的笔名写作，他运用了美国废奴主义者用来为奴役非洲人辩护的同样论点，来为北非巴巴里国家奴役欧洲人进行辩护。
So in this pamphlet Franklin writes pretending to be a Muslim propagandist for slavery. Let us then hear no more of this detestable proposition, the manumission of Christian slaves, adoption of which would by depreciating our lands and houses, and thereby depriving so many good citizens of their properties, create universal discontent and provoke insurrections. And that, of course, is exactly the language that will be used by Americans in favor of keeping slavery right the way up to the Civil War. I actually didn't know about that until I saw it in your notes. I think it's fascinating.
所以在这本小册子中，富兰克林假装成一个穆斯林的奴隶制宣传者写道：让我们不再听到这种可憎的提议，即解放基督徒奴隶，因为采纳这种提议会贬低我们的土地和房屋，从而剥夺这么多好公民的财产，造成普遍的不满并引发叛乱。当然，这正是美国人在内战前一直用来支持维持奴隶制的语言。我实际上在你的笔记中看到它之前并不知道这一点。我觉得这太迷人了。
I think it is a brilliant piece of work. And I think the debt to Jonathan Swift is absolutely there. like a modest proposal or something. And it is an act of repentance. Franklin had owned slaves. He came to repent of it. And he sought to write the wrong that he had done the slaves of America. And that piece of writing was his last to be published.
我认为这是一部杰出的作品。而且我认为对乔纳森·斯威夫特的借鉴是绝对存在的。就像《一个小小的建议》之类的东西。这是一种忏悔的行为。富兰克林曾经拥有奴隶。他后来对此感到忏悔。他试图纠正他对待美国奴隶所犯下的错误。而那篇文章是他最后发表的作品。
Because on the 17th of April, 1790, Benjamin Franklin breathed his last. And he died as he had lived as a man, prepared to follow his conscience, no matter where it might lead. And I salute him. I think he is a tremendous, a tremendous man. I think one of the more attractive people who have had a measurable impact on the course of world history, I think. Okay. I mean, he's no Dr. Johnson, but he's not too far. He's not too far short. But Dr. Johnson didn't sign for crucial historical documents and sway the fate of nations. No, that's all true. I mean, I think you could say of Franklin that had he not got, you know, French backing, history might have been very different.
因为在1790年4月17日，本杰明·富兰克林咽下了最后一口气。他死时正如他活着时一样，是一个无论良心指引他去哪里，都准备追随良心的人。我向他致敬。我认为他是一个了不起的人。我认为他是对世界历史进程产生过可衡量影响的人中，比较有吸引力的一位。好吧。我的意思是，他不是约翰逊博士，但相差不远。他相差不远。但约翰逊博士没有签署关键的历史文件并左右国家的命运。不，那都是真的。我的意思是，我认为你可以说，如果富兰克林没有得到法国的支持，历史可能会大不相同。
And he played it brilliantly. I mean, again, we've talked about the series about John Adams, who actually goes to France to kind of provide backup for Franklin. And Adams, who is very puritanical, really objects to this whole hanging out with aristocrats kind of malarkey and totally balls this up. Franklin's methods are definitely better. So I think he does change history.
而且他玩得非常出色。我的意思是，我们再次谈到了关于约翰·亚当斯的系列节目，他实际上去了法国为富兰克林提供支持。而亚当斯，他非常清教徒，真的反对这种与贵族混在一起的胡闹，并完全搞砸了。富兰克林的手段绝对更好。所以我认为他确实改变了历史。
And I think he's one, as I say, one of the more amiable figures to have changed history. Okay, brilliant. Brilliant episode, Tom. Thank you very much. Now, in our next episode, we should be looking at a founding father who went one stage further than Benjamin Franklin, and he became the hero of his own musical. And this is, of course, Alexander Hamilton. We'll be talking about the Hamilton duel with Aaron Burr. And in the final episode, Tom will be investigating the moral contradictions of Thomas Jefferson. Now, if you'd like to hear those episodes right away, you can, of course. You need to join our own band. of repressive redcoats,
而且我认为他正如我所说，是改变历史的人物中比较和蔼可亲的一位。好的，精彩。精彩的一集，汤姆。非常感谢。现在，在下一集中，我们应该看看一位比本杰明·富兰克林更进一步的开国元勋，他成为了自己音乐剧的英雄。这当然就是亚历山大·汉密尔顿。我们将讨论汉密尔顿与阿隆·伯尔的决斗。在最后一集中，汤姆将调查托马斯·杰斐逊的道德矛盾。现在，如果你想马上听到那些剧集，你当然可以。你需要加入我们自己的乐队。
the Restis History Club. And you can do that by going to the Restis History.com. You sign up, you get a whole host of benefits. You only get these by signing up through our own website, all the benefits, so you get the bonus episodes and early access and all of this kind of thing. Unbelievable enjoyment for all the family.
压迫性的红衫军，即“历史的其余部分俱乐部”（The Rest Is History Club）。你可以通过访问 TheRestIsHistory.com 来做到这一点。你注册后，会获得一系列福利。你只能通过我们的网站注册才能获得这些福利，所有的福利，所以你会得到额外的剧集、提前观看权以及所有这类东西。全家人的难以置信的享受。
Talking of all the family, we actually have our Restis History Festival this weekend at Hampton Court. Saturday, sadly, sold out. One or two tickets still available for Sunday. So great friends of the show, Ian Hislop, Helen Castor, William Dalrymple, Adam Smith and Katia Hoyer will be there. Tom and I are incredibly excited about this. So we're hoping to see as many people as possible.
说到全家人，我们这个周末实际上在汉普顿宫有我们的“历史的其余部分”节。周六，很遗憾，票已售罄。周日还有一两张票。所以节目的好朋友，伊恩·希斯洛普、海伦·卡斯托、威廉·达尔林普尔、亚当·史密斯和卡蒂亚·霍耶都会在那里。汤姆和我对此感到非常兴奋。所以我们希望能见到尽可能多的人。
You can get the tickets again by going to the rest is history.com. And we will return next time with Alexander Hamilton and Aaron Burr. So on that bombshell, thank you and goodbye. Bye-bye. This is an urgent appeal from the Disasters Emergency Committee. devastating earthquakes have hit Venezuela, resulting in widespread destruction. Thousands have been killed and injured, and survivors desperately need food, water, shelter and medical care. Go to DEC.org.uk to donate or text DEC to 70150 to give 10 pounds.
你可以再次通过访问 TheRestIsHistory.com 获得门票。我们下次将带着亚历山大·汉密尔顿和阿隆·伯尔回来。所以带着这个重磅消息，谢谢大家，再见。再见。这是来自灾难紧急委员会的紧急呼吁。毁灭性的地震袭击了委内瑞拉，造成了广泛的破坏。成千上万的人死亡和受伤，幸存者迫切需要食物、水、住所和医疗护理。前往 DEC.org.uk 捐款，或发送短信 DEC 到 70150 捐赠10英镑。
Texts cost your donation plus standard network rate. See website for T's and C's. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
短信费用为你的捐款加上标准网络费率。请参阅网站了解条款和条件。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。